COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
I'M GOING TO MAKE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
SCHEDULE WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE TUNING IN FOR THE
FIRST TIME. I'M GOING TO COVER
THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS
FOR TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE
CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF. WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE AND
LOCAL ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC. HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. ALL
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN. ARE
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE. AND AGAIN
WILL DISPLAY IT- AT LEAST ONE
MORE TIME OR TWO AS WE GO
THROUGH THE HEARING. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LAN AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU
ARE WATCHING THE HEARING ON
PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND W AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OUR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO THE
NEW ONLINE TOOLS. SO AGAIN
PLEASE BE PATIENT SO EVERYONE
CAN BE HEARD. AND LASTLY BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY ON BEHALF OF
OUR STENOGRAPHER I WILL ASK ALL
SPEAKERS IN MY COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES ALIKE. TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY IF I NEEDED
TO SLOW DOWN- I MAY INTERRUPT
YOU BUT- CERTAINLY WILL ALLOW
YOU TO CONTINUE TO SO THAT WE
GET YOUR TESTIMONY. SO BEFORE
WE BEGIN TODAY'S ADDRESS AGENDA
WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AND A REMINDER TO THE MEMBERS
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE FOR THE ROLL CALL
AND EVERY TIME WE VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ROVE HERE GROWTH HERE
HERTZBERG. HERE FOR HERE
LAYERED HERE LATER HERE BATES
HERE IT'S HERE ATKINS ATKINS
HERE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES IF WE
ARE ABLE TO I WOULD LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE- ITEM NUMBER TWO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR WE HAVE AN
ITEM E. F. AND G. LET ME ASK IF
I NEED TO SEPARATE THOSE OUT
FOR ANYONE I JUST LIKE TO MAKE
A COMMON ONE ABSOLUTELY- GO
AHEAD MR MAJORITY LEADER. YEAH
I JUST WANTED TO I COULDN'T
MOVE- ALL OF THEM IF THAT WORKS
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE BUT I JUST
WANTED TO SPECIFICALLY
KNOWLEDGE SUSAN FRIEDMAN THE
MEMBER OF THE BOARD BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES WAS A YOUR FRIEND TO
HAVE KNOWN A LONG TIME. AND-
HOLDER IN THE HIGHEST REGARD.
THANK YOU. AND FOR THE RECORD-
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. I TO II IS-
MISS SUSAN FRIEDMAN FIVE MEMBER
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES-
DI<c.cyan> HER WORK- DR DIANE HER</c>
WAKE MEMBER BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES. AND CHRISTOPHER C.
JONES ALSO MEMBER BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES SO THAT IS
ITEM NUMBER TWO- A MOTION HAS
BEEN MADE CALL THE ROLL. ROVE I
WROTE I HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG
AYE LAYERED BY THERE I BATES
ALL RIGHT I ATKINS HI A CONCISE
AND I WOULD ALSO I ENTERTAIN A
MOTION FOR ITEM NUMBER THREE
THE BILL REFERRALS. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OH FIVE I HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG BY LAYERED FIVE I
EIGHT ALL RIGHT I ATKINS I HAVE
INSIDE THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN TODAY'S GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
WITH ITEMS ONE A. AND ONE B.
AND TAKE TO MEMBERS OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF REGENTS. HEIDI MARC CARO
CORPORATION MICHAEL RECIO THANK
YOU AND I SHOULD KNOW HOW TO
SAY THAT- WE HAVE MET- AND
JONATHAN SERVICE ARE BOTH-
AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGENTS
SO LET ME- I SEE YOU BOTH
WELCOME AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS WE GET UNDER WAY
TODAY- I'M GOING TO ASK EACH OF
YOU IF YOU WILL INTRODUCE
YOURSELF MAKE ANY OPENING
COMMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE THANK-
ANYONE YOU LIKE AND THEN. WE
WILL GO TO- QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS AND
SO- HARRY WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD
AND START. WITH YOU AND THEN
WE'LL MOVE OVER TO J. THE
RATIONALE. THE THANK YOU
SENATOR PER TENTH. ATKINS AND
SENATORS- HONEY MIGRATION AND-
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND THE
OPPORTUNITY- GIVE IMAGES
HEARING. I'M VERY HUMBLED AND
HONORED FOR THE SECOND TIME I'M
PLACED IN FRONT OF YOU. TO
POSSIBLY SET SERVICE SECOND
TERM AS A REGIONAL SHE NEVER
CITY OF CALIFORNIA. IF YOU
CONFIRM ME TODAY. I CAN'T DO
THIS BECAUSE OFFICER WILL
DISTURB THESE WELL AS AND THEN
TO WORK WITH HARD WORK AND A
HUMBLE ATTITUDE. DID WHATEVER
WAS NECESSARY TO BECOME A
PRODUCTIVE MEMBER OF SOCIETY.
MY PROMISE TO MYSELF HAS ALWAYS
BEEN. MUCH SERVICE AND GIVE
BARGAINS WHICH IS POSSIBLE TO
THE COUNTRY IN THE SOCIETY.
THAT EDUCATED ME AND ACCEPTED
ME AS A MAMMOGRAM. FOR THAT
REASON I SERVE REQUIRED FOR
TWELVE YEARS ALREADY. I'M
HUMBLED THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
NOW RE APPOINTED ME TO SERVE
FOR A SECOND TERM. MY PASSION
HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO BRING
FINANCIAL DISCIPLINE IN COST
SAVINGS TO THE UNIVERSITY BY
MAINTAINING THE HIGH. STANDARDS
OF EXCELLENCE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
OUR CORPS CUTTING USES COSTS A-
SUFFICIENT ON THE LOWER. WASTE
MY BELIEF. IS THAT THE COST OF
A IS NOT ONLY TRUE. TOTAL COSTS
OF PHYSICAL MEETING COSTA BOOKS
FEES HOUSE. FOOD TRUCK THE
SEARCH FOR. EVERY THAT WE SAVE
A APPROACH CON THE- IS IT WITH
IN TOTAL COSTS OFFICIALS. OKAY
ARE LOCATED IN SOME OF THE MOST
EXPENSIVE THE REAL ESTATE
NATIONAL ASIAN PERHAPS THE
WORLD. S. ARCH HOUSING COSTS
FOOD TRANSPORTATION ETCETERA.
ONE OF THE HIGHEST IN THE
NATION. PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS STAFF AND
FACULTY WILL BRING DOWN THE
TOTAL COST OF EDUCATION ARE
MANY EXAMPLES THAT I CAN- TALK
ABOUT TODAY. BUT LEAVE MY
OPENING STATEMENT BRIEFS ON
ANSWERING QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER SERVICE GO HEAD.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM FOR TENANT
THANK YOU SENATORS VERY MUCH IT
IS MY GREAT HONOR TO BE HERE AS
WELL TODAY- THIS IS A AT LIKE
OUR REGION MODERATION THIS WILL
BE MY SECOND TERM. I WAS
APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR BROWN AND
THEN WE APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM AND TAP. I AM VERY
GRATEFUL TO BOTH OF THEM FOR
GIVING ME THEIR TRUST CHEN. IN
THIS INCREDIBLE POSITION- FOR
ME THIS NEXT TWELVE YEARS IS AN
IMPORTANT TWELVE YEARS IF I AM.
CONFIRMED THE UNIVERSITY FACES.
INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES GOING
FORWARD. FROM THE HEALTH CARE
PERSPECTIVE TO AFFORDABILITY
ISSUE TO AN ISSUE OF. EDUCATING
IS NUMBER AND THE NUMBER OF
GREAT NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS
THAT WE HAVE. TODAY SO MY I'M
HOPING TO BRING MY LEVEL OF
EXPERTISE IN. THE WORLD OF
HEALTH CARE IN THE WORLD OF
NATIONAL SECURITY IN THE WORLD
OF RUNNING A BUSINESS. LIKE OUR
REGION MODERATION SAID
OFFICIALLY AND EFFECTIVELY SO
THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CAN BENEFIT FROM
THAT. AND WITH THAT I SAY THANK
YOU AND- I AM OPEN TO ANSWERING
ANY QUESTIONS HIGH YOU MAY HAVE
FOR ME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET ME GO AHEAD AND START
SENATOR BATES- IF YOU WILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
WELCOME TO YOU- YOU BOTH OF YOU
AND CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
NOMINATION CAN I SEE I SEE
MYSELF NOT THEM. ANYWAY MISTER
MOCKERY SHE AND I DON'T MEAN IF
YOU REMEMBER HARDY- I WAS THERE
IN THE WAY OF THE ST REGIS IS
BEING BUILT IN AND YOU WERE SO
MUCH ON. THE SIGNIFICANCE STYLE
PARTNER YET NOW BRINGING OUT
BI<c.cyan> TO FULL FACILITY TO YOU-</c>
WHAT WAS THEN I THINK MY-
SUPERVISORIAL FEEL TO BE A
STREAK MY ASSEMBLY THIRTY SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT SEVENTY THIRTY
THIS WEEKEND- IT SITS THERE NOW
IS THE WALL DOOR DOOR FOR STORY
I BELIEVE- IN THE SENATE THIRTY
SIX DISTRICTS SO I YOU HAVE A
WONDERFUL WONDERFUL. REPUTATION
OF BEING OUT QUITE A BUILDER
FOR SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY AND MY
DISTRICTS UP COMBINED- QUESTION.
FOR BOTH OF YOU- STIRS OF STAND
UP. MISTER MOCKERY SHE AN OUT
I'D AND LIKE FIRST BILL ON
COBIA. ARE IN THE VACCINATION
IS. SO I KNOW. THE SO AND WHO.
REQUIRED TO GET FLU SHOPS FLU
SHOTS AND NOW WE HAVE. THE
CORVETTE VACCINATION AVAILABLE
WE KNOW THE SUPPLY OF US
CERTAINLY. THE ISSUE AT THE
MOMENT BUT DO YOU EXPECT ARE
YOU SEE. MAYBE REQUIRING COAL
THAT VACCINATIONS. BEFORE THE
STUDENTS CAN RETURN TO CAMPUSES
THIS FALL WITH THE HOPE THAT IT
WILL BE TOTALLY OPEN AND THE
SECOND QUESTION BECAUSE I'LL-
DO BOTH SO THAT YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. BOTH RESPOND TO
IT HAS TO DO WITH THE TESTING.
ARE HAVING THE UC SYSTEM MOVE
AWAY FROM THE AFTER A C. T. AND
THE S. EIGHTEENTH- AND HOW ONE
WILL MAKE OUR ADMISSION AND
SCHOLARSHIP DECISIONS WITHOUT.
THOSE THOSE INSTRUMENTS YET
STUDENTS MAY BE REQUIRED TO
HAVE. THOSE TERROR FOR
APPLICATIONS TO PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES HOW WILL YOU.
INTEGRATE TO THEIR OUT WITH
DETAILS BUT I BELIEVE YOU'RE
DEVELOPING AND TO BE IN PLACE
OF. THE SAT AND ACT THOSE ARE
SIGNIFICANT IF I LOOK AT
THROUGH MAY HAVE GRANDCHILDREN
THAT ARE CURRENTLY. IN HIGH
SCHOOL THINKING ABOUT. THE UC
SYSTEM PROBABLY FIRST AND IN
THEIR MINDS AND DIED YET BEING
REQUIRED OF THE SCHOOLS THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO ACTUALLY GET
SOME BRIEFING RIGHT NOW ON OF
THE SAT AND ACT SO. I'LL LEAVE
THOSE TWO QUESTIONS FOR YOU-
AND. TO BE LISTENING INTENTLY
THANK YOU- THIS I MAY- IS SOME
OF THE TWO. B. H. FIRST WILL
THANK YOU THOSE KIND WORDS- IN
WAS ALWAYS A- PLEASURE TO- TO
BE APART JUST ON THEIR YEAR-
DISTRICT AND- I KNOW. ALL OF
THE GREAT WORK THAT HAVE DONE-
FOR ALL OF THE SUDDEN COUNTY.
CITIES OF THAT- THE- THE- HE-
ISSUE OF THAT. SELECTION AND-
FOR- AND- CORPORATE. I WAS. OF
DR BIDEN JUNE- COUPLE IT AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT REQUIRE ALL THIS.
DIDN'T BEFORE COMING TO THE
CAMPUS AND- HER STATEMENT WAS
SET AT THE MOMENT. WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH OF ACTIONS TO.
PROVIDE YOU- FOR EVERYBODY AND
WE WERE JUST GOING TO BE GOING
ON LAYERS OF- OF- THE
NECESSITIES AS AS YOU KNOW FROM
THE HEALTHCARE WORKERS- DOWN TO
THE SOCIAL IN SOCIAL FOOD. OF
FOOD- WORKERS AND THEN- DOWN TO
THE TO THE PROFESSIONS AND-
PEOPLE LOVE TO GO AND WORK AT
THE LABS ANDDATE THE
HOSPITALIZATION THAN THAT DOWN
TO WHEN IT BECOMES MORE
AVAILABLE- TO REQUIRE THAT'S
FOR EVERYBODY BUT AT THE MOMENT
AND ANSWER THIS A- SEASON KNOW
THE ANSWER IS NO ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR. ACTUALLY
BEING VACCINATED. THE SECOND
QUESTION REGARDING THE S. A. T.
AND C. T. I BOARDED THE-
LIMITING TO ACTUALLY CHOOSE TO
TEACH ADDITIONAL. FOR STUDENTS
THE- KNOW HOW IT IS. FOR
APPROVED THOSE OF US WHO DIDN'T
HAVE THE THIS IS. RIGHT IN
FRONT OF A- TO TAKE THOSE K. TO
ESTO AND THE EXTRA OF THE-
BETTER THIS TIME ARE BOTH TO GO
SHOULD I. SURE WE ARE GOING TO
OF TRUE. CREATE OR OWN TEST.
SHOW THAT THE- OF X. AT THE U.
FOOTBALL THE AFTER AND- FOR THE-
CORRECT- HE'S NOT GOING TO-
LOWER. SHELF THAT WE- I'VE BEEN
TO THE- AND THE PRESS BUSH AND
ARE WORKING- CHIU PUT. A
USUALLY REQUIRE TEN. BUT AS YOU
KNOW IT'S VERY TOUGH TO SOME
DOES COVER IT. AND EQUITABLE
AND ALSO- WE ACCESSIBLE. OF FOR
EVERY SO WE HOPE TO THE IN THE
FUTURE WE CAN COME BACK TO AN-
AND HAVE SPECIFIC ARE. TO WHAT
THE SCHEDULING THE- AND ALSO
THE PUBLISHER OF ASKED THAT
TEST. OF STATUS IS GOING TO BE.
THANK YOU. ANYTHING YOU WANT
ADD- WHAT WHAT THANK YOU SO
BATES LET ME JUST ADD ON THE OF
THAT- YOU KNOW I THINK WHAT
THERE ISN'T AN THE SUPPLY AND
THEIR NOW WE CAN. SAID THE
EVERYBODY- YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
HAVE SAFE CAMPUSES AND IF THAT
REQUIRES PEOPLE TO BE
VACCINATED TO BE IN PERSON I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
GONNA CERTAINLY HAVE TO LOOK
AT. I UNDERSTAND WHY THERE ARE
CERTAIN PEOPLE THAT DON'T WANT
TO GET VACCINATED I DO BELIEVE
THERE SHOULD BE EXCEPTIONS TO
IT AS WELL- BUT RIGHT NOW IT'S
NOT EVEN A REAL DISCUSSION
BECAUSE THE- SUPPLY
VACCINATIONS DOESN'T EXIST. ON
THE SAT ACT ISSUE- I TO VOTED
TO- IN TO MAKE THAT GO AWAY I
HAD FELT THAT THE TEST WAS
UNFAIR. I CAN GIVE YOU LOTS OF
REASONS WHY IT'S UNFAIR- AND-
AND WE WERE ASSURED THAT THE
NEW TEST WAS GOING TO BE
DEVELOPED. IN IN ALL CANDOR I'M
SKEPTICAL OF THE NEW TESTS I'M
SKEPTICAL FOR A COUPLE OF
REASONS- I'M SKEPTICAL BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
EXPENSIVE. UNDERTAKING TO
CREATE A NEW TASK AND- I DON'T
WANT TO GO SPEND HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. ON A NEW TEST TO FIND
OUT WHERE IN THE EXACT SAME
SITUATION WE WERE WITH THE SAT
AND ACT- I HAVE SCHEDULED
MEETINGS WITH A NUMBER OF THE-
HEADS OF ADMISSIONS INCLUDING-
OF THE UCLA FOLKS. BECAUSE I
WANT TO SEE HOW. THIS CYCLE OF
ADMISSIONS FOR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WORK. AND HOW THEY WERE
ABLE TO ADMIT STUDENTS WITHOUT
USING THE TASK. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY I WANT TO TAKE A
REALLY GOOD LOOK AT. WHAT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH OUR DIVERSITY.
ABLE TO HAVE A DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION WITHOUT THE TEST.
AND I THINK THAT DATA WILL BE
FORTHCOMING IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF MONTHS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THAT. THANK YOU FOR
THOSE RESPONSES- LET ME JUST
MAKE A CLOSING LARA CROFT
COMMENT ON THE TESTING BECAUSE-
BACK IN THE DARK AGES WHEN I
WAS APPLYING FOR COLLEGE
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT I AM THE
SENIOR SENIOR MEMBER HERE- WHAT
THEY USE AT THAT TIME IT WAS
THE COMBINATION OF A GRADE
POINT. AVERAGE AND HOW MANY%
AIZEN BEES YOU ARE ACHIEVED IN
YOUR VERY OUTSIDE COLLEGE PREP
CLASSES. YEAH THAT SEEMS TO BE
A VERY FAIR UP WAY TO DO IT AND
ALSO WAS VERY INCENTIVIZING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE LOOKING TO THE UC
SYSTEM. AS A PLACE THAT THEY
WILL I WANTED TO GO AND IN
THOSE DAYS IT WAS EASIER TO GET
INTO UCLA WHICH WAS THE BIG
SCHOOL- FOR GRADUATION FROM.
THE AREA IN WHICH I LIVE SO ONE
MIGHT TAKE A LOOK AT THAT. THAT
SURELY SHOWS A STUDENTS
COMMITMENT TO HIS STUDY A
COMMITMENT TO THE ISSUE AREAS
HE WANTS TO PURSUE AND HIS
CAREER PATH. HIS OR HERSELF
THAT'S JUST A LITTLE-
HISTORICAL INSIGHT. BUT THANK
YOU AGAIN BOTH OF YOU FOR
INCREDIBLE SERVICE TO THIS
INCREDIBLE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS
THAT. STANDS ABOVE MOST YET YOU
KNOW OUR NATION. AND OUR BEST
WISHES TO YOU AS YOU CONTINUE
YOUR SERVICE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SENATOR CENTER LAWYER.
THANK YOU VERY. FROM IT ONLY
JUST MAKE BRISCOE NOT TO. AND
ALL THE START THEM. WITH THE
DIFFERENT REGION EACH TIME.
JUST THE ARE I HAD A LONG
MEETING WITH EACH ONE THEM AND
IT WAS VERY. HELPFUL AND ABLE
TO GO OVER. THERE AS SOMEBODY
THAT WAS ONCE MAYOR OF A CITY
THAT HOUSE DO YOU SEE THERE ARE
MYRIAD OF ISSUES. THAT COME UP.
AND ALSO. MANY THINGS THAT ARE
CONCERNED WHETHER IT'S
DIVERSITY WORDS HAVING ENOUGH
SPACES. WHETHER IT'S LABOR
RELATIONS OF OUR HEADS AND WE
HAD A CHANCE TO GO THROUGH THE
MALL. SO LET ME JUST ASK TO FOR
THE RECORD AND. AND REGION OF
MOSCOW READ SHE AND OUR I WILL
BEGIN WITH YOU F. NF WAS UP IN
OUR CONVERSATION YESTERDAY YOUR
BACKGROUND IN DEVELOPMENT
REALLY HELPED. IN YOU LOOKING
AT ALL THE DIFFERENT
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN TRYING TO IMPOSE SOME
SENSE OF A BUSINESS MODEL ON
IT- COULD YOU SPEAK TO THAT
PLEASE R. Y. ARE YOUR SERVICE
IS HELPFUL IN THAT REGARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION WELL- OFTEN TIMES- WE
ARE PROUD- PRIVATE SECTOR- WHEN
WE PLAN TO DO A PROJECT WE WILL
BE A CLOSE ALONE YOU KEEP ALL
OF THE INFORMATION CLOSE TO OUR
CHEST. AND REVEAL AS LITTLE
INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE TO THE
CONTRACTORS TO ENSURE SUPPLIERS
AND- AND THEN- AND- WE'VE
DESIGNED SOMETHING THEN GO FOR-
PRICING AND GETTING THE- THE
BEST POSSIBLE- NUMBER- THAT WE
CAN GET DOWN TO THE PROJECT.
UNIVERSITAIRE CUT CALIFORNIA
OPERACIJA THE REAR PART OF IT
IS THE CLOSEST IN THE LAW FOR
OF IT IS BECAUSE OF THE- THE
HISTORY ACT ON AND PAN. AND
PART OF IT IS BECAUSE THE EXTRA
OF SOME OF THE COUNTRY-
SPECIALLY- THE SPECIALTY
SPECIALTY FIELD. UP BECAUSE OF
THE MEGA. THEY UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE TO COME TO
THE REGION'S RELEASED THEIR
PROJECTS- DISCUSSION GET A
BUDGET TOGETHER AND THEN GO OF
THEM VISITED FOR THE FIRST FOR
THE BEST **** OBVIOUSLY
CONTRACTORS AND- MATERIAL
SUPPLIERS MUST LEARN OF THE
BUDGET. THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
COME INTO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S SHOWN ON OUR YOU
KNOW WHAT THIS IS 20% HIGHER
THAN. WHAT I CAN BUILD A STRONG
GOING TO GIVE YOU 80% THEY'RE
JUST GONNA CME VERY VERY CLOSE
TO THE BUDGET. CHAU IT AND
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE
REGULATIONS THEY HAVE TO DO
CERTAIN THINGS SO WHAT I HAVE
DONE OR WHAT I. HAVE USED MY
EXPERIENCE IS THAT. WHEN THEY
THE APPROACH TO THE COULD FIVE
LAW AT DATA. THE D. OF COSTA
NAY SHE IN SAID AREAS. THROUGH
HIGH. THEN ON MYERS. I SORT OF
REJECT THE PROJECT CAN AND
FORCE THEM TO GO BACK AND
REVISIT. AN OFTEN IS HAS ENDED
UP- SAVING IN REVERSING THERE
ARE MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN AS AN EXAMPLE I
COULD USE. ONE OF THE MOST
RECENT WHICH WAS- UNIVERSAL
CITY- THE SAN DIEGO CAMPUS THAT
THE THEY HAD BID- A PROJECT-
FOR- THE STUDENT HOUSING. AND
AND I LOOKED AT THE WHOLE
THING- AND SHE TO ME THAT THE-
COST US THE PARKING WHICH- WAS.
THREE TIMES TO FOUR TIMES
pHIGHER THAN. WHAT WE WERE
BUILDING IN OTHER AREAS IN-
CALIFORNIA. AND EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAD GONE TO THE AND- FLYER
AND A FORTUNE TO GO BACK AND
WITHIN THREE MONTHS. THEY WENT
FROM LUNCH WE JUST NEEDING TO
THE NEXT MAJOR RESISTANCE THEY
CAME BACK WITH ABOUT EIGHTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN.
SAVINGS THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
AREAS OF MY EXPERIENCE HAS HAS
HELPED AND- MANY EXAMPLES OF
THOSE THAT I CAN TELL YOU BUT.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME.
ABOUT A- THAT'S THAT'S FOR
WOULD BE USING MY- PRIVATE PRO
ANA. HOLDS TRUE IF I BRING AND
NASH PER. TOGETHER SO THAT THE
WE THE POWER OF THE IN. WHICH
WE SPOKE CLOSE TO FOUR DOLLARS
PER YEAR. IN ADDITION BECAUSE
SHE- PROJECTS THAT'S A- OF
POWER THAT WE CAN WE CAN. ON
PURCHASE GETTING DISCOUNTS.
THANK YOU VERY. AND IT JUST FOR
MY- FOR. FOUR WHEN I IN THIS.
ONE OF THE IS THAT BUILDING
WOULD BECOME. IT AFTER YOU SEE
CAMPUS. AND BOND MONEY WAS
AVAILABLE AND THEY WOULD JUST
YOU. KNOW IF MONEY TO BUILD THE
BUILDING AND THEN THEY WOULD
NEVER HAVE MONEY FOR THE
MEDICATIONS AND THEY WOULD FALL
ON EVERYBODY ELSE. AND I
FINALLY GOT LANGUAGE. WHICH I
WAS HAPPY LET THEM. FOR A- IN
THE BUDGET THAT STILL WOULD.
THAT YOU SEE CAN'T MONEY FOR
NEW BUILDING TELL TO MITIGATE.
THE WHAT'S COME FROM THE LAST
BUILDING AS A WAY TO FORCE THEM
TO PUT IT IN THEIR BUDGET TO DO
IT TODAY. AND THEN OF COURSE WE
STOPPED OF IN BONDS TO MINUTE
OUT. OF THAT GOT THERE. THE
OTHER QUESTION FOR REGION A
REGION SUESS. WE TALKED
YESTERDAY ABOUT OUR- SORT OF
GROWTH OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE-
ONE OF THE BIG PROBLEMS IS UC
STRUGGLES TO HAVE ENOUGH SLOTS
FOR STUDENTS BUT IT'S DOING ON
TO EXISTING CAMPUSES WITH TO
GETTING MORE MORE CHANGED. AND
I KNOW THERE'S ONE OPTION TO
THE- THE REGION'S MIGHT
CONSIDER ABOUT MILES COLLEGE.
AND OTHERS AND I WONDERED IF
YOU WOULD SPEAK TO JUST. YOUR
VIEW OF HOW YOU SEE WILL HANDLE
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL OUR
GROWTH IN STUDENTS. OBVIOUSLY
WE DID SPEAK ABOUT THAT AND
MILLS COLLEGE IS- SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE LOOKING INTO TO OUR-
THERE'S NOT. THERE IT IS AND-
HAS SOME DEEP FINANCIAL ISSUES
AND THERE MIGHT BE AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY COMING
FORTH. FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND PARTICULARLY
BERKELEY TODAY TO TAKE A TO
PICK UP SOME OF THE ASSETS OF
THAT UNIVERSITY AND THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE ONGOING I
THINK- LOOK WE ALL WANT TO
EDUCATE THE- THE MAXIMUM NUMBER
OF STUDENTS YOU KNOW PREFERABLY
CALIFORNIANS- AND GROWTH IS
GOING TO BE ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
ISSUES. I THINK WHAT THE
BALANCING ACT IS HOW DO YOU
GROW AND MAINTAIN EXCELLENCE-
WHEN WE SEE THESE- COLLEGE
RANKINGS COME OUT THEIR
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO SEE
THE MOST NUMBER OF OUR CAMPUSES
AND UP IN THE TOP FIFTY
UNIVERSITIES. IN THE COUNTRY
AND SO GROWTH IS IMPORTANT BUT
THE MAINTAINING MAINTAINING
EXCELLENCE IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT
AND I THINK THAT'S THE
BALANCING ACT THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BE- BE JUDGING GOING
FORWARD. MILLS COLLEGE COULD BE
AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY IT
WILL BE INVESTIGATED LIKE NO
OTHER AND IF THE OPPORTUNITY
IS- MAKES SENSE- WE WILL
PURSUE. A POSSIBILITY OF AN
AFFILIATION OR PURCHASE OF
WHATEVER THAT MIGHT BE BUT I
THINK IT'S A LITTLE EARLY FOR
THAT AT THE MOMENT. OKAY THANK
YU I APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOU
ARE ANSWERING QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SENATOR SENATOR BREAUX.
THANK YOU MADAM PRETEND I'M
AGAIN I ECHO MY COLLEAGUES'
COMMENTS ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO BOTH OF YOU AT
TODAY IT WAS A VERY GOOD
CONVERSATION I THOUGHT I REALLY
APPRECIATED THE FACT THAT BOTH
OF YOUR- BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
BUSINESS LEADERS. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND- HAVE THE- NO
ONE IS A COMMON SENSE OF THE
SENSE TO APPROACH- SOME OF THE
INCREDIBLE CHALLENGES THAT THAT
THIS SYSTEM THE- SYSTEM HAS- AS
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER. FROM A
BUSINESS APPROACH- WHEN
APPROPRIATE. ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT IS- YOU
KNOW TO CREATE A STANDARD OF
EXCELLENCE IN OUR SYSTEM ARE
YOU UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS WE HAVE
TO HAVE. GOOD QUALITY-
OUTSTANDING STAFF AND
LEADERSHIP. AND I GUESS ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE IS
THAT YOU KNOW GIVEN THE BUDGET
THAT WE'VE HAD WITH LOST
REVENUE OVER THE HEALTH AND
HOSPITAL WITH THE MONEY THAT
WAS LOST THERE PLUS HOUSING AND
EVENTS. AND A BUDGET DEFICIT I
GUESS YOU'D SAY I'M AND FUNDED
PENSION LIABILITIES TO THE TUNE
OF ABOUT TWENTY. BILLION
DOLLARS- WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THE BUDGET COMING FORTH TO
HELP FILL THAT GAP AND STILL
RECRUIT TOP TALENT. SO THAT WE
REMAIN S. AT OUR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM REMAINS A STANDARD OF
EXCELLENCE IN CALIFORNIA WHEN
WE COMPETE WITH OTHER STATES. I
NEED TO OUR SERVER AND- SURE
THE LOS ANGELES THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME YOU SPEND WITH US THIS
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. I THINK- AS YOU KNOW
UNIVERSITY HAS BEEN FACED WITH
THE INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
PRESSURE. AS FAR AS THE
FINANCES ARE CONCERNED AND-
HAVING THE- SHARE THE FINANCE
COMMITTEE RAN COLLUDED-
SITUATION HIT- RIGHTS LAST
FEBRUARY MARCH. WE INVEST IN
THE IN THE- I MEAN EITHER THAT
WE DIDN'T WE DIDN'T DAYS OR
WEEKS WE JUST REALLY JUMPED ON
EVERYTHING I HAVE OF MYSELF I
HAD. WITH OUR CFO AND- TRY TO
STOP EVERY TYPE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
INTERNAL SESSIONS AND THEY'RE
NOT TALKED ABOUT THIS STOP
EVERY TYPE OF INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR US SHE WAS THAT THAT WASN'T
NECESSARY OF COULD BE DELAYED.
THERE STARTED REFINISHING
EVERYONE OFF OR OLD THAT AND-
TO TAKE TOOK TOOK ADVANTAGE OF
THE LOWER RATES WE WANT TO THE
MARKET AND RAISE SOME FUNDS. A
VERY VERY LITTLE ROOM. LOW
WRETCHEDNESS AT ABOUT TO BILL
DOLLARS IN THEN THEY WILL
ANOTHER- HAPPILY A SEARCH WAS
KILLED GAPS AND WITH THE
INITIAL. CARE FUNDS- MEDICAL
CENTER IS ORDER THROUGH. CALLS
TO ABOUT SIX HUNDRED TERM LOAN
DOLLARS AND THEN THE FIRST
CARES ACT NEW SHOES TO HARM
THAT IT WAS THREE AND EIGHTY.
EIGHTY DOLLARS WAS WHICH
HUNDRED OR WAS WAS MORE WORST-
AS AND THEN DO OTHER HUNDRED
THIRTY WAS FOR. AND THEN THE
SECOND TRUMP THAT IN WITH AND
MEET. UM DO- THE TO. OF THAT
WAS ABOUT THE AGE THEY BELIEVE
IT LAST HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
NINE AGAIN HI THIRTY ONE FOR
STATE NAY DOWN THE BALANCE OF
HIS WENT THE CAMPUS IS. SO THE
COMBINATION OF COURSE SAVINGS
COMMITTEE OF REALLY WE- AGAIN
THE AND- GET D. H. WE'VE TRIED.
FILL IN THE GAP SPACE IN EVERY
OF THE HOSPITALS AS YOU KNOW
THE MEDICAL CENTERS PROVIDED
35% AFTER TOTAL REVENUE- OF FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OR CLOSE TO
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS ALL OF
SUDDEN. THEY WERE JUST TOTALLY
STOPPED WE COULDN'T TAKE ANY-
ANY ELECTIVE SURGERIES AND- AND
EVERYTHING WENT TO OVERREACH
SHOW THAT REVENUE STOP ALL OF
YOUR EVERY YEAR. PARKING'S AND
HOW STRANGE OF STUDENT HOUSING
FOOD SERVICES STATE BASED OFF
OF THOSE REVENUES THEY WERE
PROVIDING RUSSIA OF FUNDING
BETWEEN. THE UNIVERSITY
OPERATIONS BASED SO BETWEEN THE
TRUE WE FILL THE GAP AND WE
WERE ABLE TO OPERATE AT AS YOU
RELATION TO- THE BIG GAP IN-
RETIREMENT SAVINGS- THE- IT
THAT'S MOSTLY RELATED TO THE
STOCK MARKET AND AS AS YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR. OF OVER. TWO YEARS
AGO JUST ON THE PHONE THING WAS
ABOUT 60% OR IT WAS SEVEN. I
THINK OUR A BILL DOLLARS. AND
TODAY THAT'S- YOU USE YOUR POS
IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SIX BILLION DOLLAR. AND THIS
PAST YEAR FOR THE MONTH- THE
END IS GOING 6% SO- EVEN THOUGH
OUR FUND GAVE STILL AT 85% SO
PERCENT. I THINK WITHIN- WITH
STOCK MARKET NONCHALANT. OF THE
UNIVERSE HAS INCREASED EMPLOYER
EMPLOYER- I THINK WE'LL BE TO
FILL THE BACKUP AND WE ARE
HOPING. THAT THE STATE WILL
COME. SOME THE RICH I MEANT THE-
OF- RETIREES TO WHICH I FUND
LIKE YOU DO FOR- FOR. SHOW WITH
THE I THINK IF YOU ANY OTHER
MOVE A- QUESTIONS YOU WHEN I
WAS ME ABOUT EACH OF THE
ACTUALLY THE RETIRED THE- AND-
THE BE HAPPY TO ANSWER. YES NOT
SIR THANK YOU FOR MUCH AND THE
CONVERSE WE HAD THE MORNING AND
RESPOND TO THAT. I DO A- IT I
LOOK FOR TO SOME YOU. BOTH OF
YOU. YES MA'AM. IF YOU DID. TO
A QUESTION. THAT THAT EXTRA
MISTER SERVICE. I YEAH OKAY BUT
I THINK IT WAS OKAY YEAH SIR
I'M THANK YOU- SENATOR MR
MATURE LEADER GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO- IN SOME OF THE
THAT WERE TO BRING THE
ATTENTION THE PUBLIC THE FIRST
OF THE MILLS COLLEGE THE SECOND
THE CHALLENGES- OF RECRUITING
TALENT IN THE PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
WHEN WE HAVE SOME PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES THERE STILL ARE
PEOPLE IN PAIN A LOT OF MONEY
IT'S A IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE AND I ALSO WANTED TO.
GIVE HATS OFF TO- RIGID MARK
RHAETIAN FOR HIS EFFORTS ON THE
REFINANCE I WATCH THAT CLOSELY
AND THOUGHT THAT WAS PRETTY
QUITE. OF THE- INSIGHTFUL IN
TERMS OF REDUCING COSTS AND
DEBT AND REFINANCING THOSE
OBLIGATIONS. AT SIGNIFICANT
LOWER INTEREST RATES. ARM IN A
AND I KNOW THAT J. IS DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN THE ISSUES OF- THE-
THE LABS AND THE SECURITY
CLEARANCES THAT HE HAS TO
ENGAGE IN THE HARD WORK THE
GATE THEY GIVE YOU GET CREDIT
FOR THAT I JUST WANTED TO SEE
WITH A COUPLE OF THOUGHTS ONE
IT WAS I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME EFFORTS AFOOT AT THE BOARD
OF REGENTS DEALING WITH
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY. WE WERE
TWELVE THOUSAND PATENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN CREATED BY- THE
ACADEMICS AT THE UNIVERSITY AND
YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT YOUR
CHICAGO UNIVERSITY MICHIGAN IT
WAS A WASHINGTON STANFORD TO
SOME EXTENT THEY HAVE BEEN SO
MUCH MORE- AGGRESSIVE YOU THE
SCHOOL AFTER THE BUSINESS
SCHOOL AT UCLA GOT SIX OR
MILLION DOLLARS ON A RECENT
TRANSACTION IN TERMS OF REVENUE
STREAM AND EXPLOITING OF THOSE
THOSE ASSETS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE ARGUE ALL THE TIME ABOUT.
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BEING
THIS GREAT JAM OF CALIFORNIAN
WITH A SIMPLE XR AND I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT ONE OF THE GREAT
IMPACTS IS THE INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY THAT COMES OUT OF THE
UNIVERSITIES JUST WANTED TO GET
BOTH REGION'S THOUGHTS ON THAT
IN TERMS OF THE EFFORTS AFOOT.
AND WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
GOING FORWARD. NO MR MAJORITY
LEADER THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION YOU LOOK THERE IS AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY COMING OUT OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA I DO
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
TAKE A DEEPER LOOK. AT A HOW WE
COMPENSATE THE CREATORS OF THAT
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY. AS AS
HADI HAS SAID BEFORE YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE IN TRYING TO MAINTAIN
THE EXCELLENCE WE HAVE
EMPLOYEES I USE THE OUR FORMER
HEAD OF THE MEDICAL CENTER. WHO
IS MAKING A MILLION TO A YEAR
WAS WAS RECRUITED BY AN EAST
COAST COMPANY. FOR A SIX
MILLION DOLLAR SALARY AND HE
RAN AWAY FROM THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIAN ABOUT TEN SECONDS.
WE'RE NEVER GONNA PAY SOMEBODY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO RUN A
MEDICAL CENTER. WHAT I DON'T
THINK THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO
LOOK AT IS. THAT OUR COACH THE
ADVOCATING. FOR THOSE THAT ARE
CREATING. VERY VERY VALUABLE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. POSSIBLY
A MORE FAIR SHARING AGREEMENT
WITH THEM WHICH WOULD IN MY
OPINION WHAT INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE
TO PUT THEIR BEST FOOT FORWARD
TO STAY. CREATIONS TO THE
UNIVERSITY AND THAT'S SOMETHING
I THINK WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
DEEPER LOOK INTO IN THE IN THE
COMING MONTHS HERE. WHICH
MIGRATION YOUR THOUGHTS. UP IN
THE MAJORITY RETURN FOR SCHOOL-
HELLO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND- THAT YOU'VE DONE
FOR ALL OF THE CALIFORNIANS AND
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA- BUT
THE LET ME LET ME GO BACK TO
DISH THE TOOLS- THOUSAND
PATENTS UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST- REGISTER. IN AND
ARRESTED FOR ON THE AVERAGE FOR
DAYS THERE'S NO NO UNIVERSE. OF
COMMERCE- CLAUSE SLASH AND THE
PATENTS UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OF CREATES ARE
UNBELIEVABLY NOT ONLY THEY SAVE
HUMAN LIVES WELL LET'S LET'S
JUST TALK ABOUT THE GREEN
ENERGY LET'S JUST TALK ABOUT-
YOU KNOW YOU TALK ABOUT CARBON
TAX AND- AND ALL THAT STUFF BUT
JUST ONE PERSON ONE PATTON. OF
FROM- SANTA BARBARA SHUJI
NAKAMURA IS A NOBEL PRIZE
WINNER AS YOU KNOW IS IN SANTA
BARBARA AND A SINGLE HANDEDLY
SAVED THE ENTIRE WORLD YOU CALL
THEM TO TURNING OFF ALMOST
ELECTRICITY. AND ZERO AND
THAT'S HIS GROUP CREATION WAS
LED LARGE NOW UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA BARBARA IS
TRYING TO GO BACK AND COLLECT
ON SOME OF THOSE- ROYALTIES THE
HOME DEPOT ALL OF THE LED
LIGHTS AROUND THE ABOVE ME
AROUND THE AGE ALL OF OUR WHO.
TELLS ALL FOR A UNIVERSITIES IN
THAT IS DOORS ON THE PATENT
STATE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HAS CREATED AND WE SHOULD
DEFINITELY BE DEFINITELY. THE
TAKE- THEN SHE JUST WAS WHEN I
JOINED THE FIRST ON THE GEORGE
OF THE UNIVERSITY TEN OR TWELVE
YEARS AGO. THE FIRST COUPLE OF
YEARS REMEMBER LOOKING. BUT I
HAD THE SAME EXACT. QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE AND THEN WHEN I
WAS SHE WAS A- DEEP. AND BE
CLASS WAS EVEN ON ANYBODY RADAR.
IT WAS ERA EVERY CAMPUS
OTHERWISE THE LITTLE PATH AND
TRANSFER AND WHEN I THE THEN.
PRISON YOU I'VE MADE MOTIONAL
ABOUT IT PRESENT YOUR OFFER DAY-
SHOW OF CORRUPTION SAID WHAT
REGION ARE. ARE YOU CHAIR YOU
YOU GO ON TO SEE WHAT YOU CAN
DO HE SAID OF A- EACH DOUBLE
AND SHE WAS WE COULD DO I REFER
OF. THE. THE ONE OF THE CAN.
THEY HAD. LIMITED AMOUNT OF
MONEY. AND WHAT CALL THE NIGHT
INTO ON THE NATIONAL DO YOU IT
JUST AS TO WHICH- VALUE. THIS
WE DON'T DO IS JUST LIKE A IT
IS WITH WORLD I KNEW IS ON THE
RIGHT. IN FACT IF YOU LOOK THE
HIS- OR HAVE YOUR SAY TO LOOK
SOME THE RECORDS THAT ARE NOT A
JUST SENATE ON THE RECORD. HE
SAID IT'S NOT PLAYING- THE-
THE- CALIFORNIA LOTTERY WHO
PUTTING MONEY TO HOLD ME. THEY
DID NOT HAVE A- SET UP. TO
STUDY EVERY ONE OF THOSE
PATENTS AND JUST LIKE THE BIG
FUNDS IS. THAT THEY COME IN AND
BUY THE BATONS OR OR TAKE THE
PATENTS AND GIVE THE UNIVERSITY
A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY. I
SUGGESTED THAT WE SET UP
SOMETHING LIKE THAT AND AFTER
THE AFTER WAS A BIG TOOK ABOUT
SIX OR SEVEN YEARS- BUT NOW
THEY HAVE DETECTORS FOR-
FISHNETS UNDER DO YOU USE YOUR
PH AND ALSO- THE HIRED SOME.
THE ORDER I SHOULD SAY I HIRED
A DIVISION PRESIDENT OVERTURE
PRESS FIRED SOMEBODY THAT'S NOW
GETTING PAID FROM. THE REGION'S-
BUT- AND HE'S YOU IN AT EXACT
WHAT THE YOU. ABOUT SO THAT
THAT'S IMPROPER. AN OFFICE BEEN
UP. I DON'T THAT THE FUTURE-
FOLLOW IT BOTH AND I. AND ALL
THE REASONS FOR INTO. I GET
ENTIRE BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT SURE.
I'M TRYING. YEAH I JUST THINK
THAT END OF THE DAY I THINK
THERE'S A LOT MORE MONEY TO BE
MADE AS A RESOURCE FOR THE
UNIVERSITY. AND WELL AS A
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO SPLIT WITH
THE CITY CALIFORNIA- TO EXPLOIT
THAT I ACTUALLY- SPEAKING OF
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SANTA
BARBARA ACTUALLY- WORKED ON A
PROJECT WITH ONE OF THOSE NOBEL
LAUREATES IN PHYSICS OF YEARS
AGO WHEN I LEFT GOVERNMENT.
BASED UPON- THE GENIUS IDEA
THAT WAS THOUGHT OF BY THAT
INDIVIDUAL SO. BUT NO I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THANKS THANK YOU
BOTH I THINK THE QUESTIONS HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO NUMBER THE
QUESTIONS I WANTED TO ASK THE
HEAD OF MY NOTES HAVE BEEN
ASKED BY MY COLLEAGUES SO. I
REALLY APPRECIATED AND I
APPRECIATE TO. BOTH OF YOU
TAKING THE TIME- YOU KNOW TO
SERVE PUBLIC SERVICE IS JUST.
AN EXTRAORDINARY HONOR. AND THE
VERY CHALLENGING THE I'M GONNA
MEASURES LIKE SOMETIMES AT
THOSE MEETINGS WE'VE GOT
PROTESTS AND ALIKE. IF YOU'RE
EMBRACING VERY DIFFICULT ISSUES
AND TRYING TO DO A TUITIONS AND
ALL THE KINDS OF CHALLENGES.
THAT EXIST IN EXISTING
UNIVERSITIES BY THE WAY
THROUGHOUT HISTORY. HE HELPS
YOU STUDY THE WHOLE HISTORY OF
THE UNIVERSITIES IN EUROPE IN
THE KIND OF CHALLENGES THEY
FACED AREN'T MUCH DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WE'RE FACING TODAY.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
SERVICE AND YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO. TO PARTICIPATE AND BE HAPPY
TO A SUPPORT BOTH OF YOUR-
APPOINTMENTS. THANK YOU CENTER.
IS A THANK YOU MISTER MAJORITY
LEADER TOM. I AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS AND- WORDS OF MY
COLLEAGUES I GUESS I WOULD GIVE
YOU A LAST WORD OF BEFORE WE GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AND
I'LL START- WITH YOU MISTER
SERVICE- IT'S- IT'S A SIMPLE
QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK. MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE DONE A PRETTY
GOOD JOB. IF THERE WERE
SOMETHING YOU REALLY WOULD WANT
US TO KNOW- ABOUT YOU SEE. IN
PARTICULAR- IT JUST AT YOU GAVE
OPENING COMMENTS BUT WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE US AS LEGISLATORS-
RIGHT NOW TO. BE MOST AWARE OF
AS IT RELATES TO THE UC. AND
THE SYSTEM BIGGEST THING ON
YOUR MIND. WELL FOR SO THANK
YOU KNOW- I THINK ON BEHALF OF
THE ENTIRE YOU SEE I THINK WE
HAVE TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR. THE TENTATIVE DEAL REACHED
WITH THE GOVERNOR TO RESTORE
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN CUTS FOR A MILLION
DOLLARS IN CUTS THAT'S GOING TO
BE CRITICAL FOR OPERATION- I
LOOK AT THE END OF THE DAY I
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS. I SAID EARLIER. WE REALLY
WANT TO EDUCATE THE GREATEST
NUMBER. OF STUDENTS POSSIBLE WE
WANT TO MAINTAIN THE AXLE OF
THIS YOU. AND QUITE FRANKLY WE
WANT TO GROW IT- WE WANT TO SEE
ARE YOU SEE HEALTH I KNOW BOTH
HEIDI AND I. WANT TO SEE UCLA
HEALTH GROW. AND WE SEE IT AS A
TRUE BUSINESS AND A TRUE. A
TRUE WAY TO SAVE LIVES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THESE THESE FIVE
MEDICAL CENTERS ARE CRITICAL
AND THEY HAVE PROVEN THEMSELVES
SHARING CODE. TO BE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL DURING. THIS
CHALLENGING TIME SO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE SET IN STONE
THAT THEY'RE FINANCIALLY STABLE
AND THAT WE CAN CONTINUE THE
GREAT SERVICES. THOSE ARE
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
GOING FORWARD. THANK YOU MISTER
MICROREGION. I AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THAT J. J. SAID THAT
BUT- ACTUALLY DOES I THINK-
FIVE FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT IN THE PAST
AND ALSO SPECIALLY- HOPEFULLY-
CHU V. V. FILLING BACK- THE
COACHES- THAT THAT WAS DONE
BEFORE- HI IT DID THIS YEAR
AND- YOUR SUPPORT BUT MY LINE.
I REQUEST IF YOU MAY WANT TO
CALL IT IS THAT. LOOK AT THE
UNIVERSE THIS IS WHAT I LEARNED
REALLY IN THE PAST TWELVE YEARS
AND I'M SO HAPPY AND SO
GRATEFUL THAT THE GOVERNOR.
REAPPOINTED NICHE WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE UNIVERSITY. IN LONG
TERM WHEN I SAY A LONG TERM IS
NOT TODAY THIS IS FOUR YEARS IN
NEXT FOUR YEARS AND- AND-
WHETHER WE SHOULD CUT THE- SAG
OR CATV. OR WHATNOT BUT WE
REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
UNIVERSITY'S LONG TERM YOU KNOW
FIFTY YEARS A HUNDRED YEARS
DOWN THE ROAD. ONE OF THE SHOWS
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA AND
GIVING US TO SUPPORT BECAUSE
IT'S THE ONLY INSTITUTION I
THINK PERHAPS. MAYBE ONE OF THE
BEST IN THE WORLD- THAT COULD
SOLVE THOSE PROBLEMS BUT WE
CANNOT SOLVE THOSE PROBLEMS
ALONE JUST FOR THE REGION'S IN
JUST FOR THE- REVENUE THAT'S
GENERATED FROM THE UNIVERSITY A
LOT OF THE STATE'S SUPPORT OF A
LOT OF THE- SUPPORT BOTH-
DOLLAR WISE AND ALSO READ THE
LEGAL- IT DOES HE SAID- THOSE
ARE THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT AND- AND I KNOW.
EVERYONE ELSE THE YOUR ON TOP
OF IT AND- YOU CAN GIVE US A
SUPPORT- BUT I WOULD LOOK AT
THE UNIVERSITY AS A LONG TERM-
SITUATION JUST LAST MONTH
PUBLIC COMPANIES TO LOOK AT
EACH QUARTERLY AND THEY STATED
THEY FORGET. THAT THEY NEED TO
EXIST TWENTY YEARS FROM LAW WE
SHOULD NOT LOOK AT OURSELVES AS
JUST ONE YEAR OR TWO YEARS AND
WE SHOULD LOOK AT THIS
INSTITUTION AND SAVING. FOR
FIFTY TO A HUNDRED YEARS FROM
NOW SO THAT WOULD THAT'S- AND I
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE DONE AND- SHOULD. BE
PORTION OF IT IS DOLLARS. WELL
THANK YOU I. YOUR COM AND YOUR
TO- WE'RE GOING IF I NOTHING
FOR MY- WERE GO TO MY OF THE-
THE WILL BE HERE WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH MEMBERS IN SUPPORT.
I AND WE'RE GONNA START RIGHT
HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE AND- NOT SEEING ANYONE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE I'M
GONNA LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE
OUR SECOND ROOM TO MAKE SURE.
WE COVER THAT BASE NO ONE IS
THERE. SO I AM NOW GOING TO GO
TO THE TELECONFERENCE- AND-
INTRODUCE AND WELCOME OUR
MODERATOR- TO ASK IF YOU WILL.
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THESE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF REGENTS. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU-
MADAM MODERATOR WILL BE BACK
WITH YOU IN A FEW MINUTES- WE
WILL COME BACK IN I. TO SEE IF
THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION BUT AGAIN SAYING NO
ONE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE. ALSO SEEING NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE MADAM MODERATOR WE
ARE ALREADY BACK TO YOU TO SEE
IF THERE ARE WITNESSES THROUGH
TELECONFERENCE WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR WE
WILL HEAR FROM YOU AGAIN LATER
SO- LET ME COME BACK I
RECOGNIZE OUR MAJORITY LEADER
GO AHEAD WHICH SHOULD MAKE A
MOTION. OKAY OUT WE HAVE A
MOTION LET ME JUST ASSURE YOU
IT DOESN'T ALWAYS FLOW THIS
EASILY SO- WE GET WE CAN MAKE A
LITTLE ROUGHER IF YOU'D LIKE
BUT- WITH THAT MOTION ON THE
FLOOR FROM OUR MAJORITY LEADER
LET ME ASK THE SECRETARY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND THE
MEMBERS TO TURN ON THEIR BIKES.
ROVE I. WROTE AYE HERTZBERG I.
PROVIDE A LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES ALL RIGHT IT'S AYE
ATKINS. AYE ATKINS NINE. FIVE
TWO ZERO. FIVE TWO ZERO AND LET
ME THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO OUR GREAT SYSTEM
CONGRATULATIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY WE ARE GONNA
I'M GONNA SEE IF OUR STERN ARE
REFERRED NEED TO BREAK YES
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE- KNOW
YOU'RE OKAY. I RECOGNIZE THAT
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA GO FORWARD
TO NEXT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO-
ITEM ONE SEE. AND THAT WOULD BE
THE APPOINT APPOINTMENT OF
MICHAEL J. RICH WINE THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION. LET ME SAY WELCOME
TO YOU MISTER RICHWINE. ASK IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE BY THE WAY
AND ASK IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS
RECOGNIZE ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE
WITH YOU AND THEN WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO MEMBERS. OF THE
COMMITTEE. WELL. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING MY NOMINATION FOR
STATE FARM. I'M JOINED
VIRTUALLY BY. GRADE CLASSROOM.
IN THE ANTELOPE MY CHILDREN.
OUR SERVICE THROUGH INTO AND
WITH OUR OUR STAKEHOLDERS AND
PARTNERS. IMPLEMENTED PROGRAM.
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS WITHIN THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE
JUST SO THAT I COULD. AND
BECOME MORE REAL WELL RIGHT. OR
SHOULD IT ALONG THE WAY I HAVE
ESTABLISHED. VERY POSITIVE.
RELATIONS WITH MEMBERS OF THE
THEIR SERVICE. AND ALL AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
THESE PARTNERSHIPS ARE CRITICAL
IN OUR MISSION WHICH IS TO
PROTECT. THE LIVES IN THE
PROPERTY OF THOSE WHO LIVE WORK
AND PLAY IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDERATION AGAIN OF
MY NOMINATION AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS. I THANK
YOU FOR THOSE OPENING COMMENTS-
THAT WAS INCREDIBLY INSIGHTFUL
AND HELPFUL MR MAJORITY LEADER
LET ME START WITH YOU. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU ARE FOR SURE
YOUR OFFICES WORK ON THE SWING
SPACE IN THE NEW BUILDING.
PRESHEAF THAT. I KNOW IT'S NOT
A BIG ISSUE THE MOST BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. BOB OTHER
ISSUE I WANT YOU IN OUR
INTERVIEW ELOISE. IN THE PUBLIC
ARENA. DISCUSSION WE HAD
REGARDING DEFENSIBLE SPACE
OBVIOUSLY IT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S
A VERY BIG THING FOR US THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR.
LEGISLATORS IN BOTH HOUSES THAT
REPRESENT COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY IN FIRE. CHALLENGE
JERRY AND AS WE ARE ENGAGING ON
PACKAGES AND DISCUSSIONS FOR
LEGISLATION AND BUDGET REQUESTS
ON DEFENSIBLE SPACE. OFTEN THE
ISSUE IS IMPLEMENTATION YOU
KNOW WE CAN TALK ABOUT AN IDEA.
BUT WHO'S ON THE GROUND THAT
ACTUALLY HOW DOES THAT WORK HOW
DO YOU TELL SOMEBODY TO GO TO
CUT THE TREES DOWN THAT HAVE
BEEN THERE FOR A HUNDRED YEARS.
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH FOLKS
WHERE THERE'S A CHALLENGE TO
THE COMMUNITY ON THE ONE HAND
IN TERMS OF FIRE RISK AND YET
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER HAND.
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THAT AND
YOUR OFFICE IS THE OFFICE AS WE
ENGAGE IN THIS POLICY. IT'S
GOING TO BE THE FACE OF THIS
AND SO I WANTED TO GET SOME OF
YOUR INSIGHTS. ABOUT HOW YOU
INTEND TO DEAL WITH THIS IN THE
VERY HUMAN. WAY THAT MEETS OUR
GOALS ON THE ONE HAND AND YET-
IS RESPECTFUL TO PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES ON THE OTHER. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR.
AND YOU KNOW WE DO RESPECT THE
PROPERTY OWNERS- PROPERTY AND
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW IT CAN
BE DIFFICULT FOR THEM WHEN WE
SHOW UP OR SOMEONE SHOWS UP AND
TELLS THEM THAT THEY HAVE TO
REMOVE VEGETATION. BUT WE ALSO
EDUCATE THEM ABOUT THE
CRITICALITY OF IT WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
HUNDRED FEET OF SPACE THAT OUR
CREWS CAN OPERATE IN THAT WILL
SLOW THE PROGRESSION OF THE
FIRE AND GIVE OUR FIRE CREWS A
CHANCE TO SAVE THEIR HOME. NOW
WE ALSO OFFER THEM
OPPORTUNITIES FOR- YOU KNOW NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT
WORK IN THEIR COMMUNITY THAT
CAN THAT CAN PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO THEM- BUT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
WE HAVE QUITE A CHALLENGE. AND
THERE WERE UP TO THE TASK OF
THE GOVERNOR- HAS PROVIDED US
WITH EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
ADDITIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. THOSE PEOPLE
WOULD BE OUT DOING THAT DOING
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND THEY'LL
ALSO BE DOING SOME SOME OF.
YOUR CREWS WORK- SO- YOU KNOW
IT'S THE LAW WE UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT- REALLY IT'S A PERSONAL
THING AND SO WE TAKE THE
EDUCATION APPROACH AND WE'LL
ABOUT 80% COMPLIANCE RATE. ON
OUR FIRST INSPECTIONS WITH ARE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTIONS
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU
GUYS FOLLOW YES. YEAH I GET THE
80% NINETY I THINK IT'S
FANTASTIC I GET IT AND I THINK
THE HEARING FIFTY EIGHT NEW
PERSONNEL IS GREAT. IT JUST
WORRIES ME AS WE ENGAGE YOU
ALL. OF MY OFFICE HAS WORKED
AROUND THE CLOCK DEALING WITH
EDIE CLAIMS SOLVING OVER A
THOUSAND OF THEM. AND LAST WEEK
THERE WAS A STORY IN THE LOCAL
MEDIA THE COMMUNITY THAT I
REPRESENTS WHERE A GENTLEMAN
SAT ON THE PHONE FOR NINE
HOURS. AND THAT WAS THE STORY
RIGHT NOT THE THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT WE SERVED AND I JUST AS AS
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE IN
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE. TO HAVE
LEGISLATIVE REVIEW OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH I CAN'T STRESS
ENOUGH HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
BECAUSE IT REFLECTS ON ALL OF
US IN GOVERNMENT WHETHER WE'RE
ELECTED OR APPOINTED OR
CONFIRMED. A TERMS OF PEOPLE
HAVING CONFIDENCE IN GOVERNMENT
SO ALL I CAN SAY IS THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE AREAS WHERE. WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES I THINK
WE'RE GONNA SIGNIFICANT RISK
COMING THIS FIRE SEASON IN THE
HEAT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SUFFER. AND THE LIKE WITH
STREAM CLIMATE CONDITIONS AND
THAT PLEASE JUST IN EVERY
RESPECT POSSIBLE TO GO THE
DISTANCE TIMES TEN TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY ARE
TREATED WITH RESPECT. AND THAT
WE DON'T END UP HAVING THOSE
NINE OUR- MEDIA CAUGHT THE
REPORTS OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE HAD
CHALLENGE I KNOW IT'S NOT
PERFECT AND WE LIVE IN A
SOCIETY OF HUMAN BEINGS BUT I
JUST WANTED TO STRESS THAT. AS.
MUCH AS I POSSIBLY COULD ISSUE
IN J. IS VERY CHAO. AND
ANYTHING YOU VERY MUCH SIR.
THANK YOU ARE. CENTER GROVE
THANK YOU MADAM I'M- THANK YOU
NUMBER ONE OF ACCEPTING THIS
HUGE CHALLENGE OF BEING THE
STATE'S FARMERS AND THAT TAKES
COURAGE AND SO THINK YOU FOR
THAT. I HAVE MICHAEL A SIM TO
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S QUESTION-
DO YOU SEE AS YOUR POSITION
THIS STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
ASSISTING COURAGE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IMPLEMENT BETTER
EMERGENCY PLANS. THE BETTER
LAND USE DECISIONS- OR LOCAL
ORDINANCES FOR FIRE PROTECTION
SPECIFICALLY IN AREAS WHERE OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE CHALLENGED BY
HIGH FIRE- EXPOSURE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION SENATOR- WE
HAVE A LAND USE PLANNING
PROGRAM WITHIN THE OFFICE. YEAH.
HANG ON HANG ON A SEC WE'VE
LOST YOUR OF VOICE- SO LET'S
SEE WITH WHAT WE CAN DO TECH.
NOW THAT YOU'RE BACK OKAY YEAH
I WAS I WAS MUTED SOMEHOW- IT
FOR THE CREW THANK FOR THAT
QUESTION- AS YOU NORMALLY USE
PROGRAM SPECIALIZES IN WORKING
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT LOCAL
PLANNING AGENCIES BUILDING
OFFICIALS FIRE DEPARTMENTS. IN
AS THEY BEGIN TO OPEN UP THEIR
THEIR- THEIR HOUSING ELEMENTS
OVER- AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
THEIR SAFETY ELEMENTS IN THEIR
GENERAL PLAN- THERE'S A HAVE
NINETY NINE CAN. THAT WE BUT-
IN FIFTY SIX COUNTIES. AND WE
HAVE ALREADY COMPLETED SEVENTY
EIGHT OF THOSE REVIEWS AND
WE'RE CONTINUING TO MAKE
CONTACT WITH THE WITH THE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS. AS WE WANT TO BE
A RESOURCE FOR THEM WE DON'T
TELL THEM WHERE TO BUILD OR
WHAT TO DO WE JUST PROVIDE THEM
WITH INFORMATION- AS IT RELATES
TO- FIRE HISTORY AS IT RELATES
TO EGRESS FROM SUBDIVISIONS AND
WATER SUPPLY. AND SO YOU KNOW
WE DO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
REACHES OUT AND WORKS WITH THE
LOCALS. WE'RE ALSO DEVELOPING A
TRAINING PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE
PILOT TESTED A COUPLE TIMES AND
WE'RE WE'RE FORMALIZING IT NOW-
ON LAND USE PLANNING DECISIONS
FROM A FIRE PERSPECTIVES
WORKING WITH OPR- IT ALSO
WORKING WITH OPR TO. UPDATE
THEIR TECHNICAL- ADVICE ON ON
LAND USE PLANNING SO WE'RE
ENGAGED- AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND- WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF GOOD
COORDINATION AND COOPERATION
AND WE DO THIS ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF FORESTRY WE SUBMIT OUR
OR REPORTS TO THE. BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION.
THANK YOU SIR MUCH. THANK YOU
CENTER LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- IT WAS GREAT TO MEET
WITH YOU AND I SHOULD INDICATE
THAT WE HAVE WORKED TOGETHER
BEFORE AND GO OUT OF THEIR
OFFICES ARE DECISION IN A GOOD
WAY FOR ME UP WE HAD A LIKE THE
TALK AND I JUST THOUGHT I WOULD
ASK ONE QUESTION. OF BERGEN ON
THE RECORD AND THAT IS IN. IN
THE LAST DECADE THE FIRE
MARSHAL WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
DOING BUILDING STANDARDS
INSPECTIONS. AND THERE WAS THIS
INCREDIBLE BACKLOG AND IT WAS
WORKED. TO BE ELIMINATED AND I
WAS JUST GONNA ASK WHAT'S THE
STATE OF THE BACKLOG AND IF AND
WHEN. AND HOPEFULLY WILL BE
CONFIRMED. WHAT WOULD YOU DO TO
MAKE SURE ANOTHER BACKLOG
DOESN'T ACCUMULATE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION SENATOR
LAYERED AND I'M AND YOU KNOW
YOU WERE AGENCY SECRETARY WHEN
WE WERE GOING THROUGH A
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
IN HELPING US TO THE RIGHT SIZE
THAT FIRE LIFE SAFETY DIVISION.
NOW WE WERE SUFFERING FROM. A
VACANCY RATE OF ABOUT 44% WE'VE
BEEN A READ IS. AND WE WORKED
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION- TO.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TO DO A WORKLOAD ANALYSIS A
DEEP DIVE INTO WHAT IT INTO
WHAT CARTER. STRIPS STATUTORY
ROLE AND RISK. ARE AND THROUGH
THAT PROCESS IT WAS DISCOVERED
THAT YOU KNOW WE WERE
UNDERSTAFFED. AND WE WERE
THANKFUL THAT- IT MINISTRATION
AND CORSET APARTMENT FINANCE
HELPED US TO WRITE A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL THAT WOULD JUMP.
OUR STAFFING SIGNIFICANTLY WE
ALSO AUGMENTED OR DEPUTY STATE
FIRE MARSHAL'S WITH. ARCHITECTS
AND MECHANICAL ENGINEER AND WE
HAVE NOW IMPLEMENTED ELECTRONIC
PLAN REVIEW WHICH ELIMINATES
THE BACK AND FORTH MAILING OF
THESE LARGE PLANS WHICH
CONTRIBUTES TO THE BACKLOG. AND
YOU'RE ON TO PAINTING OF FOR
YOU OF ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE BEFORE THAT WE HAVE
NOW THE RESOURCES AND SO- YOU
KNOW OUR OUR TURNAROUND TIME IN
PLAN REVIEW. IS PROBABLY A
MONTH AT THE MOST- I DON'T HAVE
THE CURRENT NUMBERS FOR YOU.
BUT IT IS IT IS SIGNIFICANTLY
BETTER THAN IT WAS. AT THE
COMPLAINTS HAVE CERTAINLY GONE
DOWN RIGHT I'M USED TO. GET
CALLS FREQUENTLY FROM HER MANY
SAVE A HOUSE FROM BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND TO TALK
ABOUT. THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND I'M SURE. THAT
HAS TO BE A REAL MOTIVATION.
INVENTION YES SIR- BUT WE GOT
IT FIXED AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
STILL NOT RESTORE WORK WITH
THAT OF TRYING THERE MISSION
BASED BUDGET REVIEW TO CONTINUE
THAT ANALYSIS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO BE RIGHT
SIZED. AS YOU KNOW THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
INSPECTIONS ARE GOING I MEAN
CONSTRUCTION THAT IS GOING ON
DOWNTOWN NOW WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO OCCUPY IN OUR NEW
RESOURCES BUILDING HERE AND SO
WE HAVE WE HAVE MANY CHALLENGES
BUT OUR STAFF FOR OUR HIGHLY
TRAINED. AND THEY'RE UP TO THE
TASK. GREAT THANK YOU FOR THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION AND
I'LL SEE AT THE- DEDICATION
CEREMONY FOR THE NEW RESOURCES
BUILDING VERY. THEY'VE SAID
THEY'RE GOING TO INVITE ALL
LIVING FORMER SECRETARIES ON.
TO MAKE THAT CUT. YEAH YOU GOT
IT EVERYTHING TO MAKE OR BATES
GO- THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU
MUCH OF FOR YOU SERVICE BUT
YOUR- IS SO IMPRESSIVE THAT
USED THIS ABOUT IN. EIGHTY AND
A- THE WAY YOU LOOKING MASSIVE
AND TWO THAT IS THAT RIGHT.
THAT TIME IT IS A VERY
IMPRESSED RECORD AND I CAN'T
IMAGINE SOMEONE MORE QUALIFIED
TO OUR- FOR THIS VERY VERY CHEN.
TO AS COLLEAGUE MENTIONED- IN
MY CAN- WELL TALK ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT IN SOUTH ORANGE
OVER YEARS WE WERE REQUIRE TO
HAVE. NOT PLAN AS PART OF OUR
GENERAL. AND THE MY PARTICULAR
REGION- WE DO HAVE. I'VE
REACHED ON KIND OF THE
MATERIALS ETCETERA BUT I'M AM
WONDERING IF YOU'LL BE WAITING
IN. FINCHER IF ANSWERED A
QUESTION IS THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
WITH. ON THE ISSUES THAT. HOW
DID YOU WITH FIRE RISK
ESPECIALLY IN ARE VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD ZONES WHICH COVERS
A GOOD DEAL OF THAT THE COASTAL
AREA IN MY DISTRICT THAT RUNS
FROM LAGUNA BEACH IS ALREADY IN
MY DISTRICT THAT AND MEDIALLY
SENT. ALL THE WAY DOWN THE
COAST AND THERE'S A NUMBER OF
OTHER PROTECTED OPEN SPACES
ALONG THEIR- GETTING THE GOLD
OUT TO- TO KIND OF TAKE THE
UNDERBRUSH OUT HIS BAND A MAJOR
PROJECT IN OUR- ASCEND ORANGE
COUNTY AND I'M NOT SURE IF THEY
USE THEM IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
BUT I KNOW THAT WE MAY BETTER
EFFECTIVE IN THE LAGUNA BEACH
AREA BECAUSE WE HAVE THOSE
HORRIFIC FIRES. BACK IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSAND SO WITH THE
DENSIFICATION- OF GOING ON IN
TERMS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT IN TRYING TO INCREASE
OUR HOUSING STOCK IT SEEMS TO
ME WE MIGHT BE APPROACHING
SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE THE
FORK IN THE ROAD ON WHO GETS TO
SAY WHAT. ON A DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT THAT MIGHT IN FACT. BE
A DENSIFICATION AN AREA THAT
DOESN'T MEET THE STANDARD OF AN
EVACUATION ROUTE AND I CAN GIVE
YOU A NUMBER OF THOSE IN MY
DISTRICT WILL YOU BE WAITING A
ON ON ANY OF THOSE PLANS WILL
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND I NEED TO
REACH OUT TO YOU OR HAVE YOU
ALREADY REACHED. OUT WITH THIS-
OUT RICHARD DOING WITH THESE
COUNTY SO WE KIND OF HAVE SOME
GUIDANCE BEFORE WE GET INTO.
LOCAL RESIDENTS- I'M NOT I'M
NOT GONNA CALL AND THEN BE
BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S A
LOTTERY THAT THOSE DEVELOP. NOT
IT TO PROPERLY- WITH DARK. OUT
BUT WE WILL NEED IN OUR OUR YOU
SAY OR THE PHONE FROM IS GOING
TO WAY AND SAY THAT THAT
PROJECT IS GOOD. BUT LOCAL THE
SAID NO AND I STAND WITH THEM
ON THAT ONE WILL THERE BE ANY
SORT OF LOCAL ADJUDICATION ON
SOME OF THESE ARE PROPOSALS
WHICH- NOT SAYING THEY ARE
NECESSARY BUT THERE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLACE IN
MANY OF THE COUNTY GENERAL
PLANS THAT BECAME PART OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PLANS. THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO MEET. SOME OF THE
STANDARDS SO THAT JOBS ARE
GOING TO A LITTLE THE LACK OF
OVER IS BETTER WAY TO SAY
THAT'S GOING TO COME FOR.
NGUYEN PUSHED TO SHOVE. SO I'M
VERY CONCERNED. BOB WE HAVE
SOMEONE. YOU KNOW THIRD PARTY
ROLE THAT WILL US OUT. KIND OF
WORK OUR WAY TO SOME OF THE
KINDS THAT CERTAIN WILL DEVELOP.
WONDER IF THE FIREMARSHAL WILL
HAVE ANYTHING ON ANY ROLE IN
OUT. THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
THE QUESTION- OUR LAND USE
PLANNING PROGRAM AS I MENTIONED
YOU KNOW WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENT
PLANNING OFFICIALS BUILDING
OFFICIALS. WE WILL REVIEW
PROPOSED SUBDIVISION- MAPS AND
WE WILL PROVIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT- TYPOGRAPHY FIRE HISTORY-
AND REALLY WE'RE DOING THIS IN
IN IN. CONJUNCTION WITH THE
DEELOPMENT OF THE SAFETY
ELEMENTS FOR THEIR LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS FOR THEIR
GENERAL PLANS IN THE HOUSING
ELEMENT- THAT IS THAT IS OUR
ROLE WE DO THIS ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION WE SEND THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BOARD OF
FIREBIRD THE BOARD OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION WHO THEN
WILL- SEND RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THE LOCALS BUT THIS IS ON THEIR
SAFETY ELEMENTS IT'S NOT ON A
SUBDIVISION OR PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENT BASIS IT'S A REVIEW
OF THE SAFETY ELEMENTS OF THE
GENERAL PLAN. SOME OF THAT IS
THAT IS THE ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GIVEN TO US AND
WE WHAT WE WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION THAT IF THEY CHOOSE
TO BUILD THE SUBDIVISION THEY
WILL HAVE ALL OF THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED ABOUT THE
HAZARDS. THAT EXIST. THERE IS
VERY. AND I WILL KEEP THAT IN
MIND AS WE GO FORWARD NINE. I
SERVED ON THE ORANGE COUNTY
FIRES ALREADY FOR MANY YEARS
AND WINDOWS VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD ZONES. OF CAME FORWARD
TO FIVE THERE WAS A LITTLE PUSH
BACK BUT THEN IT BECAME
SOMETHING THAT WAS SOLVED VERY.
THAT WAS REALLY EMBRACED IN OUR
COMMUNITY SO I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A PLAN OUT THERE AND
PEOPLE BEEN FOLLOWING AT THAT
TIME. THE LATEST IN TERMS OF
ARE YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT NEED
FROM OUR HOUSING STOCK- WE HAVE
A COUPLE OF BY I WOULD SAY THE
REGULATIONS THAT ARE KIND OF
BUTTING HEADS HERE AND INSOME
OF THE AREAS. SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT IS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND OF. YOUR COMMITMENT
TO THIS AREA FOR SO MANY
DECADES SIZE VERY IMPRESSIVE SO
YOU WILL HAVE MY STRONG.
SUPPORT FOR THE STRAIGHT LINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR THANK
YOU SENATOR. I ONLY. HAVE ONE.
YOU MENTIONED TO US. I KNEW
POSITIONS BUDGETED- IT AND IT
IT MADE ME THINK OF THE-
TRAINING CADEMY YOUR OFFICE-
IT HAS OVERSIGHT FOR THE
CALIFORNICA ME. AND ALSO
ACCREDITS LOCAL FIRE AGENCY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRAINING
ACADEMIES IN CALIFORNIA I'M
JUST CURIOUS HOW HAVE THOSE
ACADEMIES GONE. GIVEN COVE IN
NINETEEN- IF YOU WANT I TELL ME
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT. YES
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION-
COULD NINETEEN SHUT DOWN ALL OF
OUR TRAINING ACADEMIES YOU KNOW
DURING DURING THE GOVERNOR SHUT
DOWN THE- THE COVERT SHUT DOWN-
THROUGH MAY THROUGH JUNE
HOWEVER WE WERE ABLE TO ADAPT.
AND TO A HYBRID FORMAT AND
RESUME CLASSES BY BY AUGUST AND
SO- MANY OF OUR ACCREDITED
ACADEMIES OFFER FIRE FIGHTER
TRAINING THAT IS HANDS ON
TRAINING- THIS IS THE CYCLE
MOTOR SKILLS DEVELOPMENT OF
FIREFIGHTING ALWAYS THE LADDERS
AND. AND YOU KNOW. USING USING
THEIR POWER OF QUICK AND FORCE
AND EXIT OR SO THOSE SKILLS
HAVE TO DO ON THE FIRE GROUND
WE HAD TO EMPLOYMENT SAFETY.
SUCH AS MASS. AND THEN JUST
STEP. PUTTING THEM INTO SMALL
SQUADS COHORTS. AND HAVING DO
THE- AND SCENARIO. AND THEN IN
THE DELIVERY WE MOVED TO ALL
VIRTUAL DELIVER- AND SO WE HAD.
AND WE ARE. WE DO A- TWENTY PER
2225% LOSS- IN IN OUR STUDENTS
DRIVE COUNT STUDENT HOURS. BUT-
I THINK THAT WE WILL BE PICKING
THAT BACK UP- DESCRIBE HERE
BECAUSE WE WE'VE REALLY
COMPLETELY ADAPTED TO COPE IT
FROM A LEARNING ENVIRONMENT-
AND IF WE EVER DO GET BACK TO
NORMAL LITTLE BEING EASY
TRANSITION BACK TO THE
CLASSROOMS IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN THE FIRE. FIRE
TRAINING CENTERS AND THEN BACK.
OUT ON THE DRAW GROUND AS WELL.
WELL THANK THANK YOU FOR THAT-
AND ALSO I WITH MY COLLEAGUES
YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
SERVICE. WE ARE GOING TO GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT. OF
MICHAEL J. RICH WINES I AND SO
I'M GONNA START RIGHT HERE IN-
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE BUT
I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GIVE
THE REMINDER TO PEOPLE WHO MAY
WANT TO JOIN VIA
TELECONFERENCE. ABOUT THE ODD
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND IF WE'RE ABLE TO PUT IT
BACK UP ON THE SCREEN IT'S.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE- WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND START HERE IN ROOM
pDON'T SEE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE TO TESTIFY I'M
LOOKING AT ROOM ONE TWELVE
AGAIN. I DON'T SEE ANYONE
APPROACHING THE PODIUM. SO I'M
GOING TO GO TO OUR MODERATOR-
MATAMATA RAIDER IF YOU CAN GO
AHEAD AND R. T. UP THE- PEOPLE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
TO IN CURA JUST BE ONE MOMENT
FOR THE FIRST ONE OKAY THANK
YOU. AND WE'RE GOING TO LINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PATRICK MORAN HERE
WITH THEIR LEADING ASSOCIATES
WE REPRESENT CAL FIRE LOCAL TWO
EIGHT EIGHT ONE THE SEVEN
THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN WHO
ANSWERED MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND EMERGENCY CALLS IN
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR. IN THE
FIREFIGHTERS WANTED VERY MUCH
TO BE ON RECORD TODAY AND THEIR
SUPPORT FOR MIKE BRIDGE WHITE
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL. EVEN
THOUGH THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
LOCAL EIGHT EIGHT ONE SAID IT
BEST. WHEN HE SAID THAT MIKE
RICH WHITE APPROACHES WITH A
STABLE OKAY. THAT HE THINKS
FIRST FOREMOST OF THE SAFETY OF
THE KEY OF CALIFORNIA. CHEAPER
TRYING BRINGS ABOUT QUALITY TO
THE JOB GREAT INTELLIGENCE IT
GERRY OCT BE BACK BECAUSE CLOSE
WITH ME. I WAS NOT. IN UNDER.
THAT WILL REMAIN OF. ON BEHALF
OF COUNTY FIRE. WE SUPPORT MIKE
WHICH FIRST FARM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH HARPER. MADAM
MODERATOR NEXT. SPEAKER THANK
YOU BYE FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. GREAT- GET MADAM CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS IT WOULD SHOW UP I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. THE CBI A
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS ITS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
CONFIRMATION OF CHEAP RICHWINE.
CALIFORNIA STATE FIRE MARSHAL
I'VE HAD THE GREAT PLEASURE AND
C. B. I. A. AS WELL HAVING
WORKED WITH THE CHIEF FOR MANY
YEARS- ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES
ESPECIALLY OVER THE LAST
DECADE. AS HE HAS SERVED THE
STATE AS OUR SYSTEM STATE FARM
MARSHALL AND ACTING STATE FIRE
MARSHAL. AND I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPERATIVE DENOTE THE CHIEF
RICH WINDS PLAYED A CRITICAL
ROLE IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
STATE FIRE SAFETY BUILDING
STANDARDS INCLUDING THE
NATION'S FIRST SET OF
MANDATORY. WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE FIRE SAFETY BUILDING
STANDARDS AND WITH THAT CB I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR CHIEF RICHWINE.
CONFIRMATION TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WIT PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER TEN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT THE CHRISTIE
BELMONT BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. NEED TO BE STRONG
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF.
STATE FARM. BUT SHE'S A LITTLE
LAW AND STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
CAL FIRES JOINED PROGRAM. TO
THE CALL OF LABOR MAN PARTNERS.
BREAK GROUND ENTRY DEVELOP OF
OUR NAY GEN OF FIRE. AND NOW AS
A THE PHARMACIST HE THE CO
SPONSOR OF THIS. I HAVE BEEN ON
IN RECRUITING WHILE TRAINING
FOR FUNDING FOR FROM THE RANK
OF THE RECORD INTO GROUP. AND
THEN SHARED A PRECIOUS TRAINING
IN THE COMPASS IN THE MISSION
OF STATE PARKS AND I WOULD LAST
SAY THE VERY. NEAR TO A MINOR
HARD. HE OVERSAW THE- OF
UPDATED CURRICULA FOR THE FOR.
ONE TWO. CENTER IN. ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND HELP
FIGHT. CAN ENGAGE IN HEALTH
CARE IN DEALING WITH THE TRAUMA
THAT THEY FOR EVERY DAY AND SO
WE ARE PROUD BE HERE. OF MR
TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH- NECK
WITNESS. THANK AFTER IF YOU
WISH IN PLEASE PRESS AND ZERO
THIS TIME. THE WAY LINE NUMBERS
BETWEEN GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE CAN
STAY HE WITH THE COUNTY BURKE
WITH THE THAT. REPRESENTING
FIVE WORLD STATE WIDE. I AM
PERSONALLY WORKED WITH CHIEF
RICH ONE ON OF IT THROUGHOUT
HIS TIME AT THE- OF THE STATE
FARM. AND HE HAS WORKED
DILIGENTLY OUR MEMBER COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT YEAR THROUGHOUT THE-
IN THE STAND LAW AND- ALSO WE
THE ISSUE AND PLAN AND HOW. TO
BRING OUR MEMBERS ALL BOARD AND
AS AND SORT OF AN- THE- TO THE
YEAR AND THEN. TO GET BETTER
PLANNING BETTER STAY. THAN JUST
FOR THE CASE OF PUBLIC AND
THERE WERE. WE HAVE HAD A VERY.
RELATIONSHIP WITH CHEAPER TO
THE AND WE VERY MUCH FOR TO GET.
NOT WORKING THE FUTURE. AND WE
URGE SUPPORT HIS COMP TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY FOR WHICH. THANK YOU HAVE
NO FURTHER THANK YOU AT THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY WE
GOING TO COME BACK IN ROOM
THREE ONE NINE ONE I GO TO
ANYONE WHO MIGHT WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I'M
LOOKING AT ROOM ONE TWELVE.
THERE'S NO ONE APPROACHING THE
PODIUM THERE SO- MADAM
MODERATOR WE'RE COMING RIGHT
BACK TO YOU FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM MODERATOR I WILL COME
BACK INTO- THE COMMITTEE. AND
SEE IF THERE IS A MOTION. I
THINK- CENTER GROVE BEAT YOU
THIS TIME MR MAJORITY LEADER G.
SO- I WILL ASK MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SONOMA
HOMES. GROWTH IS THAT INCLUDES
THE ETHICALLY I MOVE AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
LAYARD HI AYE FAITH HI AIDS AYE
AT HI I THINK I THINK
GRADUATION FIVE AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR. THANK YOU
MUMBLE. THANK YOU MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOU OKAY I AM GOING
TO LOOK TO I NEED TO SEE IF SHE
WOULD LIKE A BREAK WE'RE GOING
TO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK AND MR YOUNGER WE
WILL BE RIGHT WITH YOU AND I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
INCREDIBLE PATIENCE.
AND THE-
WE WILL GO TO OUR- LAST
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT.
REQUIRED TO APPEAR THAT IS ITEM
ONE D. THE APPOINTMENT OF
MICHAEL L. YOUNGER. AS A DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
LET ME WELCOME YOU AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
MISTER YOUNGER- OFFERED TO- IT.
LET YOU GIVE OPENING COMMENTS-
RECOGNIZE ANYONE YOU WOULD LIKE
AND WE WILL GO FROM THERE AND
I'D TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
SO WITH THAT WELCOME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH I JUST WANT TO CHECK TO
MAKE SURE YOU'RE ABLE TO HEAR
ME YES WE HEAR YOU GREAT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M GRATEFUL TO BE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. I LIKE TO
THINK GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR THE
TRUST AND CONFIDENCE HE HAS
BESTOWED UPON ME WITH THIS
APPOINTMENT. AND THE TIME EACH
OF YOU TO MEET WITH ME PRIOR TO
THIS HEARING. I'M ESPECIALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE LOVE AND
SUPPORT OF MY WIFE AND TWO
CHILDREN. I WHICH HAS ALLOWED
ME TO PURSUE THIS IMPORTANT
ENDEAVOR. MY PASSION AND
PERSONAL CONNECTION FOR THIS
WORK IS DEEPLY ROOTED IN THE
CYCLE OF POVERTY THAT IS
PLAGUED MY FAMILY FOR
GENERATIONS. IT INFORMS MY WORK
AT THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY EVERY SINGLE
DAY. WHEN I WORK TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIANS PARTICULARLY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IMMIGRANTS
FORMALLY INCARCERATED AND
OTHERS YEARNING TO EXPERIENCE
THE DIGNITY OF WORK I THINK
ABOUT MY MOTHER'S FIRST WORK
EXPERIENCE IS PICKING COTTON
AND GRAPES IN THE FIELDS OF
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA. WHEN I WORK
WITH EMPLOYERS FROM THE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE SECTORS UNIONS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WORKFORCE BOARDS TO CREATE
MORE PATHWAYS TO GOOD JOBS I
THINK ABOUT MY MOM A SINGLE
MOTHER WHO WORKED TO LOW WAGE
JOBS TO SUPPORT MY SISTER NOT.
WHEN I ENGAGE WITHYOU ENTERING
THE JOB MARKET AT THIS MOST
DIFFICULT TIME OR HELP THE
DEPARTMENT UNDER THE LABOR
AGENCY TO WORK SMARTER AND MORE
STRATEGICALLY. LEVERAGING
PROVEN BUSINESS PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT AND LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT PRACTICE IT I
REMEMBER THE PERIOD OF TIME
WHEN MY FAMILY LIVED IN A
SHELTER FOR MOTHERS AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND ALTHOUGH OUR
RESOURCES WERE INSUFFICIENT. WE
WERE DETERMINED TO USE WHAT WE
HAD WISELY. WHEN I FOCUSED ON
MENTORING AND GUIDANCE
COUNSELORS BEING AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT OF THE STRUCTURE OF OUR
PUBLIC WORKFORCE PROGRAMS I
REFLECT ON MY YOUTH EXPERIENCES
THAT THE BOYS AND GIRLS CLUBS
OF MONTEREY COUNTY. AND I'M
REMINDED OF MY DESIRE FOR
MENTORING AND ROLE MODELS AND
AVOID THE COMMUNITY CENTERED
ORGANIZATIONS FEEL FOR SO MANY.
THESE ARE THE EXPIRY THAT ARE
PREPARE ME FOR THIS ROLE IN
ADDITION TO MY EDUCATIONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND OVER
THE PAST NEARLY FIFTEEN YEARS
IN THE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR. MY AWARENESS OF
NATIONAL AND STATE AFFAIRS
REGARDING SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES
WERE PEOPLE OF COLOR AND MANY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED WITHIN THE
WORKFORCE ECOSYSTEM COMBINED
WITH ISSUES OF PAY EQUITY AND
INCLUSIVITY. OUR CONCERN IS
THAT I ASPIRE TO IN BED IN THE
WORKFORCE INITIATIVES THAT I
HAVE THE GREAT HONOR TO LEAD.
APPLE AGENCY WE HAVE OVERSIGHT
OVER SEVEN DEPARTMENTS BOARDS
AND PANELS AND MY ROLE AS
DEPUTY SECRETARY HAS PRIMARILY
BEEN FOCUSED ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. BUILDING PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT EMPLOERS AND
EMPLOYEES BUT ALSO DEVELOPING
OUR OWN LEADERS WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WORKFORCE MORE
THAN ELEVEN THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
AND INTEGRATING EQUITY AND
STRATEGIC PLANNING AND TO ALL
OF OUR WORK. I SEE MY ROLE IN
SUPPORTING THE LABOR AGENCIES
MISSION TO PROTECT AND IMPROVE
THE WELL BEING. OF CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT AND FUTURE WORKFORCE AS
PRIMARILY TO PULL BOTH
EXTERNALLY. AND INTERNALLY
EXTERNALLY I DEVELOP AND LEAD
INNOVATIVE INITIATIVES THAT CUT
ACROSS OUR VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS
BOARDS AND PANELS SUCH AS OUR
EFFORTS TO HELP EMPLOYERS BILL
BACON POSITIONS. THROUGH
ALIGNING EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS WORKFORCE PROGRAMS
AND TRAINING WITH AN EYE TOWARD
EQUITY. EXAMPLES INCLUDE THE
PATHWAYS TO STATES SERVICE
PROGRAM WHICH IS A HIGH ROLE
TRAINING PARTNERSHIP THAT I
LAUNCH TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
QUALITY JOBS AND ENHANCE CAREER
PATHWAYS. FOR WORKERS WITH HIGH
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
INCLUDING THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED DISPLACED WORKERS
AND LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
THIS CROSS AGENCY CROSS SECTOR
COLLABORATION SUPPORT AGENCIES
RECRUITMENT NEEDS BUILD
KNOWLEDGE OF THE STATE'S
EMPLOYMENT PROCESS WITHIN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
AND OFFERS PARTICIPANTS
WORKFORCE READINESS TRAINING
CAREER COACHING MENTORING EXAM
TEST PREP IN A SUITE OF
WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO PREPARE
THEM FOR SUCCESSFUL STATE
CAREER. ALSO KNOWING DURING
TIMES OF ECONOMIC DOWNTURN YOU
EXPERIENCE HIGHER LEVELS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPARED TO
PRIMARY WORKING AGE ADULTS I
SPEARHEADED THE LAUNCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
CORPS. A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS GOVERNMENT
PRIVATE SECTOR AND EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS AIMED AT YOUTH
INTERNSHIPS AND- LEARN
OPPORTUNITIES CREATING CAREER
PATHWAYS INTO COMMUNITY CHANGE
CAREERS WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
ENSURING THAT YOU RECEIVE A MIX
OF COLLEGE COURSES. DEEP
IMMERSION IN COMMUNITY WORK.
COLLEGE CREDIT MITCHELL AS WELL
AS CAREER PREPARATION IN
MENTORING. I'M ALSO LEAD ON
SECTOR PARTNER LIKE OUR
PARTNERS WITH YOU YOUR A CAREER
PATH FREE IN COMPTON AND
OAKLAND. WHICH WON'T MORE TO
HUNDRED HIRES OVER THE NEXT
NINE WITH WORKFORCE SUPPORT TO
ENSURE THEY ARE SIX IN THE NEW
CAREER. PUBLIC PROJECTS BRING A
THIS WERE THE BOARD LOCAL BOARD
THAT APART OF A PRINTER STATE
IN THE- BY THAT A OF
CORRECTIONS AND PRINT IS
PRESENT. AT THE- COORDINATING
FOR INMATES AND PRIME SECTOR TO
MEET HIM NEEDS FOR SKILLED
WORKERS BUT ALL. CALIFORNIA'S
NEED FOR GOOD JOB NEXT. ON OUR
EFFORTS PRISON TO A POINT AND
THEY SHOULD. INTERNALLY I'M
WITHIN AGENCY OPERATIONS AND
INTERNAL ALIGNMENT MY FOCUS IS
TO INCREASE COLLABORATION OF
THE MAJOR DEPARTMENTS BOARDS
AND PANELS UNDER THE AGENCY'S
PURVIEW. I WORK WITH THESE
LEADERS TO MAKE SURE OUR WORK
IS STRATEGIC SMART IMPACTFUL
AND MAKES THE. BEST USE OF OUR
RESOURCES. OUR IS WHY IN AUGUST
TWENTY TWO ITEM IN LAW OF THE
AGENCIES COLOR. LEE ACADEMY.
THIS A NINE MONTH ACADEMY FOR
FIFTH EXIT AND SENIOR LEAGUE
SPOKE ON OPERA. THANK FOR.
ORGANIZED PERFORMANCE AND
CULTURE DEVELOP STRATEGY AND
PLANNING TO PRACTICE EQUITY
PRINCIPLE. AS WELL AS FOR
COLLAB. AGAIN I'M SO INCREDIBLY
GRATEFUL TO BE YOU. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS. TO THE BEST OF MY
ABILITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
YOUNGER TOM. MISTER MAJORITY
LEADER DO YOU WANT TO. THE YEAH
I JUST WANNA THANK YOUNGER FOR
HIS. HARD WORK IN PREPARING FOR
THIS HEARING IN- DURING MY MANY
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD OF HIM
DURING THE INTERVIEW PROCESS
AND HIS WILLINGNESS TO WORK SO
HARD IN THIS PRESENTATION AND
ARTICULATING IN AN ELEGANT WAY
I THINK THE WORK THAT HE'S
DOING IN HIS. IN HIS- IN HIS
JOB AND TO THANK HIM FOR THAT
AND TO TELL AND KEEP UP THE
GOOD WORK SO I GOT. THANK YOU
THE SENATOR GROVE. WELL I'M
GONNA FEEL BAD AFTER THAT M.
THANK YOU MR YOUNGER FOR- THE
CONVERSATION THAT YOU AND I HAD
HEARING ABOUT OUR MOMS- AS WE
GROW UP I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS I'VE QUESTIONS ABOUT
EDT I'VE QUESTIONS ABOUT POGBA
I HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT- SEND.
US SOME OF THE DEPARTMENTS THAT
YOU'LL OVERSEE SO I GUESS WE
COULD START WITH PAGA OBVIOUSLY
WE KNOW THAT PART IS A PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT AND IT
OPERATES AGREED EMPLOYEES TO
FILE LAWSUITS OUR STEP IN THE
PLACE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WHO USE WHITE FILE HI THERE I'M
SORRY I THINK- THE STERN ORDER
FOR NEED TO DISPLAY ZERO DOWN
IT. YES THEY ARE YOU. PAGA OF
THE FOR IT WAS JUST- BY THE
LATE. IT LOS. LIKE THAT TO BE
FOR BY THE ATTORNEY. OFFICE NOW.
A PRIVATE EMPLOYEES CAN STEP
INTO THOSE POSITIONS TO FILE ON
BEHALF OF THE OTHER- EMPLOYEES
IN AN ORGANIZATION OR BUSINESS.
AT THE L. DAVEY DAB IS THE
ENEFACTOR OF PAGA CASES- AND
WHERE THE STATE RECEIVE 75% OF
THE SETTLEMENT OR THE- AWARD
AMOUNT- CAN YOU GIVE ME YOUR
OPINION ON PAGA AND WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT IT. JUST YOUR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU SENATOR-
GROW I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
AND SO- ALTHOUGH I'M NOT
INVOLVED ON THE ISSUE- PAGA AND
WHILE I KNOW THE ISSUE HAVE A
IN THE IN THE STATUTE- THE
DEPARTMENT OF UNNATURAL AND
MORE SPECIFIC THE LABOR OFFICE
IS REALLY CHARGE BUT
ENFORCEMENT I BELIEVE- THAT
DELAY TO- ANY PREVIOUS SESSION-
SPEAK WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE OTHER SHE IS A VERY. TO YOU-
AND YOUR FOR THIS CALL CONVERSE
BY AND HER- POP UNIT OCCUPY A
FROM REGARD AND FORCE UNDER
CURRENT LAW IN A TO YOUR- IN
TERMS OF- MORE IN ON THAT MAYBE
WERE FAR SO I'M HAPPY TO BRING
THIS UP BACK OUT TO THE TEAM TO
THE LEAGUE OF THE COMMISSION
FOR FUTURE FOLLOW IF THEY WOULD
PLEASE I. I'M EIGHT. YOU
GETTING BACK TO ME ON THAT I'D
I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT VERY.
AND FIFTY NOW T. B. A LATE AND
WORK FOR DEVELOPMENT AGENCY THE
L. D. D. A. WHICH YOU'RE GOING
TO BE THE UNDER SECRETARY OF.
THE OVERSEEN YOU KNOW DEPART OF
EMPLOYMENT OF AND JUST REALLY.
VIDEO EVERY RELATIONS IN ME AS
DEPART- ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
HAD- WITH EDT FIASCO THERE WAS
AN AUDIT THAT WAS PERFORMED BY
THE INDEPENDENT AUDITOR. IS IT
YOUR RECOMMENDATION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ACT ON THOSE- AUDIT
REQUEST FROM THE AUDITOR. SO
SENATOR- YOU KNOW- WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT I THOUGHT I HEARD IN
THERE- THAT- THE UNDERSECRETARY
AND SO I JUST WANTED TO GET
JUST ONE OF. OKAY IN TERMS OF
MY I REQUEST FOR YOUR SUPPORT
IN A YOUR COLLEAGUE. ISSUES FOR
THE SAID. SPECIFIC AND- I
WANTED- JUST DISAPPOINT IS IT'S
JUST A TWENTY WHERE. AS WELL
AND SO- ZERO WHAT I WAS. I'M.
SORRY SIR YOU DID I STE I MISS
IT IS STEP SICK NOT AND- UPON.
NO PROBLEM AT ALL AND SO- KNOW
ALTHOUGH I'M- IS. IN THE- YEAH.
IF YOU WERE ON THE DAY TO DAY I
AM VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE
LEADERSHIP- THE PUBLIC BY UNDER
OF. AS WELL AS HER I NEWLY
INTEREST CHIEF- WHO ARE VERY ON
BOTH THE FINDING- UNDER A- THIS-
TEAMS READY- IT AND ALL OF OLD
MAN AS WE AND SO I MY COLLEAGUE
THAT AT THE LABOR. WHO HAVE-
EXPERIENCE IN A- ON DE AND YOU
AYE AND THE MYRIAD OF A VERY
CHEN- PROGRAM A MAN AT THEIR A
RESPONSE FOR- ARE VERY. TIED TO
YOU LEADERS WANTED TO BASIS AND
SO- I APOLOGIZE I DON'T HAVE TO
SHARE THAT BUT TIME- BUT I I'M
MUCH TO TAKE THAT INTO SYSTEM
INCLUDE- WITH THE AND FOR ALL
OF. I WOULD JUST ASK YOU ONE
TOP LEVEL QUESTION AND THAT IS
THE- YOU HAVE YOU ARE. STARTED
AND THEN WITHIN A MATTER OF
WEEKS WE WANT AND TO THE DOWN
AND THE LOCKDOWN- WAS A LOT TO
ADVOCATE FOR. ACT AS THE H. WAS
COME STRESS AND- THE CLIENT
FLOW INCREASED BY HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WHAT CHALLENGES IN ADVOCATING
FOR EQUITY IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT DID YOU FACE. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE QUESTION
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IT
SEEMS LIKE WITHIN DAYS I WAS A
LITTLE OVER THIRTY DAYS AFTER-
COMMITTING TO- YOU KNOW THIS
ROLE AND HAVING A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BE APPOINTED TO
THIS ROLE THAT THE PANDEMIC
YET. AND WHAT- I MEET AT LEAST
ROUGHLY WAS THAT- THERE WAS AN
HONOR THINK RIGHT- OF- YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY SIX- IN ARE THE
BOARD THAT REALLY. ROSE TO THE
SURFACE AT THE WAY. AND THE PEN
MAKE A REALLY YEAH. THE LADY
THAT EVEN MORE MORE READ MAY MY
WILL EVEN MORE AND MORE- ANY
MORE AND I SHOULD SAY- AND SO I
WAS COMPLETELY HUMBLED BUT I
HAD TO IMMEDIATELY HIT THE
GROUND RUNNING THERE WERE
ABSOLUTELY NO TO. SO THE PRO
THAT I WITH TODAY OUR- THAT
HAVE BEEN PLAN FOR LIVE- THE-
THE I STEPPED IN- WHEN WE ABOUT
WHAT AREAS WE WANTED TO ADDRESS-
THERE WAS A INCH KIND OF. AND
TASK LOW A BIG EVEN IMPORTANT
SO- TO SHOW THAT I CAN YOU KNOW.
THAT THAT I SHE WITH YOU. BACK
RECOVERED ITSELF I THINK THAT
WAS A BIG TASK CONTINUES TO BE
A BIG TASK I THINK SECONDLY I'D
SAY ESTABLISHING KIND OF THAT
LONG TERM VISION- BY
INTRODUCING SHORTER PLANNING
CYCLES THAT ARE ADAPTABLE TO
NEW INFORMATION AND ECONOMIC
SHIPS IN AVAILABLE JOBS AND
WILLING EMPLOYERS AND- YOU KNOW
AND THE NEED FOR SKILLED
WORKERS RIGHT AND THIS
CONTINUES TO BE. A THINGS THAT
THAT I STAY UP LATE AND WORRY
ABOUT IT. AND PUT MY MIND TO
THE TASK AND LEVERAGE THE
INSIDE AND TALENT A MOTHER
AGENCY EERS IN OUR DEPARTMENT
AS WELL AND SO I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION NOW
BUT BUT- IT HAS BEEN A
WHIRLWIND BUT BUT- YOU KNOW I'M
SO MOTIVATED BY THE COST OF
LAND TO BE PARTNERSHIPS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
STRONG PARTNERSHIPS AND- OTHER
STATE AGENCIES THAT. THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP STRONGER PARTNERSHIP
WITH- TO REALLY MEET THIS
MOMENT WRITING SO I'M NOT FOUND
AT THE VISION BEHIND MY
POSITION AGAIN IS MORE RELEVANT
THAN EVER AND AS YOU KNOW- I
STRIVE TO. MEET THE CHALLENGES
OF THE MOMENT I'LL CONTINUE TO
LEVERAGE PARTNERSHIPS ARE AND
WORKING ALONGSIDE OTHER STRONG
ENTITIES LIKE THE LEGISLATURE.
TO MOVE CALIFORNIA FOR MORE LET
ME JUST OFFER ONE COMMENT AND
THAT IS THAT- I SAID ON THE
JOINT AUDIT COMMITTEE AND WE
HAD. TO PRETTY ASTOUNDING
AUDITS ABOUT E. D. D. AND THE
ORDER MADE A RECOMMENDATION I'M
DOING A BILL WITH MAJOR
BIPARTISAN- ARE. CO AUTHORS.
THE ORDER RECOMMEND THAT HE DID
DO. A RECESSION. PLAN SO THE
WHEN THE NEXT RECESSION HIT
SENATE WILL. DAD EDT IS READY
AND I WOULD ASK OF YOU MAY BE
THAT HE WOULD TAKE PROVIDING
THAT BILL PASSES IS SIGNED INTO
LAW I DO HAVE TO IMPLEMENT.
THAT YOU TAKE THE LESSONS THAT
ARE LEARNED HERE. AND INTEGRATE
THEM WITH THAT PLANNING PROCESS
SO THAT THE EQUITY QUESTIONS
YOU'RE ACTUALLY PLANNING TO
ADDRESS. AHEAD OF TIME AS WELL
AS YOUR PLANNING JUST HOW IT
WILL BE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO ANSWER
THE PHONE TO DO EVERYTHING
ELSE. THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN THIS
TIME IN THE- OF. IT BECAUSE I
THINK IT'LL GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THE LESSONS
YOU LEARN FROM THIS AND- AND
HAVE THEM READY FOR THE NEXT
TIME THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR INTO. THANK YOU SIR
APPRECIATE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES. I THANK YOU AND OUR
FIRST OF ALL FIRST AND FOREMOST
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
NOMINATION FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT A POSITION WITH FAN
NO- OUR LABOR LABOR
DEPARTMENTS- I'M GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE PAGA ISSUE- WITH
JUST A COMMENT- BECAUSE FINDING
COURAGE- IN YOUR RESPONSE TO MY
COLLEAGUE THAT HE WOULD TAKE
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS BACK FOR
DISCUSSION ON BEING THAT IF NOT
IN THERE. ARE SPECIFIC
JURISDICTION BUT WE KNOW THE-
PAGO LAWSUITS DO TARGET THE
SMALL MINORITY AND MANY TIMES
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES THEY'RE
USED TO SHAKE DOWN THESE
BUSINESSES AND I THINK OUR
LOOKING AT REFORMS ARE
SPECIALLY OF FINANCIAL AS WERE
COMING OUT OF THE COLD AND
HOPEFULLY FOR BUSINESSES AND I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU A
COMMENT I GOT FROM. THIS
INDIVIDUAL NOT REALLY A
CONSTITUENT BUT IT HEARD ME
SPEAK ABOUT TRYING TO GET FROM
PARGA ATTENTION TO PAGA AND
REFORMS THAT MIGHT BE NEEDED
BECAUSE HE SPECIFICALLY
MENTIONS THAT IT WAS A VERY.
WELL INTENDED LAW WHEN IT WAS
INITIATED BUT IT IS GONE YOU
KNOW IN A DIFFERENT DIRECTION
IN TERMS OF THE HORRIBLE IMPACT
IS MAJOR SON AND HE'S I'M JUST
GOING TO REVIEW ONE SENTENCE
BECAUSE IT IS WHAT CAUGHT MY
EYE AND THOUGHT WAS IMPORTANT
TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION. HE
SAYS IT IS UNBELIEVABLE THAT
CLERICAL ERROR SIGN CHECK STUBS
AND TIME SHEETS COULD COST
MULTIPLES MORE THAN THE FINES
AND PENALTIES ASKED BY CAL OSHA
FOR A WORKPLACE DEATH IN
APPARENTLY HAS EXPERIENCED
BOTH. SO WHEN WE SEE THAT KIND
OF INEQUITY AND I KNOW YOU ARE
VERY VERY HARD ON EQUITY YES
CERTAINLY I THINK CRIES OUT FOR
A REVIEW AND A POTENTIAL REFORM
NOT TO UNDERMINE THE GOOD SIDE
OF DEATH TO PROTECT OUR WORK
FORCE. BUT IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO PROTECT. OUR BUSINESS SAYS
WHO WE'RE TRYING TO COME. AND
WHO. MAKE MISTAKE ARE MADE IN
THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE IT
LOOKS LIKE HE HIGH A CONSULTANT
TO LABOR CONSULTANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT HIS PAYROLL AND HOW HE
WAS DISPENSING. OUR HEROES ARE.
THE PAGE JACKSON AND THERE WERE
A FEW ERRORS I HAVE BEEN NOT
HIM NOT LESS THAN THREE OR FOUR
MEETINGS WITH MY BUSINESS
OWNERS IN MY DISTRICT. HAVE
EXPERIENCED SIMILAR THINGS OVER
THE TIME I'VE SERVED WHICH IS
NOW. ABOUT MY APPROACHING SIX
AND HALF YEARS SO PLEASE TAKE
THAT UNDER ADVISEMENT I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
EQUITY TO DIGGING DEEP INTO THE
ISSUES THAT ARE AFFECTING OUR
CERTAINLY OUR BUSINESS.
COMMUNITY OUR REGIONALLY AND
STATEWIDE BECAUSE OF IF THERE'S
SOMETHING THAT REALLY REALLY
NEEDS OF PEOPLE TO COME TO THE
TABLE AND FIGURE OUT HOW
MODIFICATIONS. WILL PROTECT THE
ACT BUT ALSO PROTECT THOSE WHO
ARE SUBJECT TO IT. SO WITHOUT
ON AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND- IF YOU COULD GET
BACK TO ME. R. ON MAY BE TAKING
A LOOK AT THIS THING THAT'S
VERY SIMPLE WORK TALKING
CLERICAL ERRORS THAT WERE
UNINTENTIONAL I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF. REVIEW THAT CAN GO ON
TO ENSURE THAT IT WASN'T GAMING
THE SYSTEM THAT IT WAS
UNINTENTIONAL I THINK THIS
WOULD BE A WONDERFUL MESSAGE.
THAT ARE STRUGGLING AND ARE
FEARFUL OFTEN FEARFUL. OF THIS
COMING THEIR WAY WHEN THEY'RE
JUST RECOVERING OR THEY'VE JUST
STARTED BUSINESS. AND FRANKLY
ARE SOME OF THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY NEED TO KNOW THEY
HAVE TO HIRE CONSULTANTS TO
HELP THEM NAVIGATE SOME OF THE
US AND THAT SEEMS TO BE ALMOST
A DONOR TO. OUR MINORITY WOMEN
OWNERSHIP STARTED BUSINESSES
THAT WE ARE ENCOURAGING THROUGH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. SO WITH
THAT- THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
SERVICE I WILL LEAVE YOU WITH
THAT AND HOPE THAT YOU'LL GET
BACK TO ME AND- I SHARE SOME OF
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S REALLY SOMETHING
THAT FELT LONG OVERDUE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THANK YOU. I OKAY I'M
GOING GO AHEAD AND GO TO
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC- THAT WOULD
LIKE SPEAK SUPPORT. OF MR
YOUNGER. I AM GONNA DO THE
REMINDER ONE MORE TIME OF THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE.
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE
SEVEN SIX ZERO NINE. SO WE WILL
START WITH WITNESSES HERE AND
AGAIN I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. SO I'M GONNA LOOK
AT ROOM ONE TWELVE TO MAKE SURE
NO ONE HAS SHOWN UP THERE. TO
TESTIFY I DON'T SEE ANYONE
APPROACHING THE PODIUM. SO I'M
GONNA GO BACK TO OUR MODERATOR
WHO HAS BEEN STANDING BY TO SEE
IF THERE ARE WITNESSES ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF MR
YOUNGER. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR OKAY WE WILL- LOOK TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AGAIN
THERE IS NO MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE I CONTINUE TO SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE SO MADAM
MODERATOR I AM. COMING BACK TO
YOU. OF FOR PEOPLE WHO MAY BE
ON THE LINE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
US TODAY MADAM MODERATOR WE
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY I'M GOING
TO COME BACK INTO MR MAJORITY
LEADER I LIKE TO MOVE THE-
APPOINTMENT OKAY A MOTION BY
OUR MAJORITY LEADER. AND IF I
SEE NOTHING FURTHER MADAM
SECRETARY EVERYONE TURN ON YOUR
BIKES- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ROVE HI ROB BY
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT BURKE I
LAYERED HI THERE HI FAITH HI. I
ATKINS HI CAN FIVE FIVE TWO
ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO MR YOUNGER
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR. OKAY ARM I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WEREN'T
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS YOUR COMMENTS IN
YOUR SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE PUBLIC RECORD. SO THANK YOU
ALL. FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND YOUR
COOPERATION TODAY ARE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES IS NOW
ADJOURNED.